so michael sussman former clinton
campaign lawyers not guilty
not guilty of lying to the fbi and uh
already we're seeing a lot of liberals
say that the whole russiagate hoax
narrative is fake news because all of
these journalists who wrote that donald
trump was colluding with russia while
they've got pulitzers that the
convictions in the russiagate
investigation well they've all stood up
to the test of time
but the durham probe nothing so far
well actually what we learned in the
investigation is that it's all basically
true that hillary clinton signed off on
spreading bunk information to the media
and then this guy went to the fbi and
misrepresented himself at least that's
what they claimed and the jury said well
they couldn't meet the burden
but many conservatives are saying
actually the issue is twofold one it's a
dc jury several of the jurors that were
uh in the jury pool donated to hillary
clinton now we don't know if they
actually made it to the jury because it
was anonymous but one even said they
they would try their best to be
impartial that's amazing
and uh uh
yeah that's true incredible they'll try
the other the other issue is that tom
fitton said
when you try to make the fbi the victims
no one's well you've got no you've got
no case the issue was that the fbi were
co-conspirators at least that's what
he's he's arguing i think ultimately
anybody who thought there was going to
be accountability at least for now
in the russia gate narrative
surprise surprise
i gotta admit it feels a little boring
you know i was like this is the big news
everybody saw this coming in fact a lot
of people i know who are deeply
entrenched in politics were like i
haven't really really paying attention
because this is exactly what we thought
was going to happen so we'll talk about
that we got a bunch of other crazy
stories there was a fire at a chicken
factory it fired a chemical plant now
apparently the mainstream media says
these fires are conspiracy theories
there's no there's nothing here nothing
happening but we'll talk about that
gas prices once again at a new record uh
yeah also so hold on weak just like
everything's worse yeah we know i got a
comment on this they were arguing that
it's not fake news because journalists
want poulters for reporting on it right
is that their actual argument well they
want awards it's really nice right
evidence all right well
we i've brought him up a number of times
but just look into walter durrante a man
who literally covered up millions of
people being starved to death for the
new york times and then won a pulitzer
prize for it which pulitzer refused to
revoke upon re-examining the case we're
going to talk about all of this and uh
as many of you may have already noticed
we have brandon strzok joining us
hey everybody
what's going on who are you what do you
do well i'm brandon strock i created the
walk away movement in 2018 and uh which
really caught fire for a few years and
then um
you know
the clouds came in 2020 uh shortly after
the election and i had a pretty rough
year for the last year and a half i
think we'll get into it tonight right
yes yeah yep
what up but i'm really happy to be
attention i'm just not no i wasn't sure
if you wanted to say something
yeah it's hot today my name is uh
sheamus coughlin uh i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes and i don't
know if you guys know this i don't know
if you guys know this but i just
launched the website freedomtunes.com i
want to plug we're selling subscriptions
five bucks a month you'll get us help
get us independent from big tech you'll
also get extra cartoons that the public
doesn't get one extra cartoon a week we
got like got a bunch of videos up there
now you guys will love it it's freedom
tunes t-o-o-n-s yes that's right but if
you put if you spell it wrong as many
people do it'll take you to the oh
that's hardcore dude
hey everybody ian crossland here uh from
ian crossland.net nothing to report yet
but man am i looking forward to hanging
out and talking tonight maybe talking
about gun control or something oh
definitely yeah uh ian was talking about
how he thinks everybody should have high
powered siege weapons yes as i started
to think about if you find yourself as a
defender which basically what these
weapons are to defend our rights and our
liberty uh if you're being attacked they
will set up forward operating bases in
entrenched positions and you still need
are going to need to assault the
attacker to get them out of the attack
formation so i love this i love right
now that uh they're sharing this clip of
me saying the second amendment protects
your right to keep and bear arms
including nukes and biological weapons
yeah and they're like they don't
understand legal versus moral arguments
i'm like i'm not saying people should
have them i'm saying second amendment
says arms and that's never been changed
other than we've just kind of
culturally and passively said okay to
restrictions because no one's going to
get a noob right but i digress well i
have always kind of thought that people
should be able to own anything that the
military can own that only seems fair to
me but i also digress i'm also here in
the corner pushing buttons how to do it
for these guys let's get going before we
get started head over to timcast.com and
become a member to help support our work
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from the tim castillo
podcast we're gonna have one up for you
it'll be published around 11 or so p.m
you'll also be helping make sure we can
maintain our infrastructure we've got
some we've got some conversations happen
in the background about
changes we want to be supporting
companies that are more resilient to big
tech censorship so we're trying to
figure out how to implement these best
that will be coming soon but don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's talk about this
story here from the post-millennial
trump slams corrupt legal system
following acquittal of michael sussman
our legal system is corrupt trump wrote
right so uh perhaps trump will get
reelected and then i'll start firing all
these people we'll see this is a story
from cnn hillary clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman was acquitted tuesday of
lying to the fbi in his first trial in
the first trial of special counsel john
durham's investigation the verdict is a
major defeat for durham and his justice
department prosecutors who have spent
three years looking for wrongdoing in
the trump russia probe he claimed
sussman lied during a 2016 meeting in
which he passed a tip to the fbi about
donald trump and russia
the d.c federal jury deliberated for six
hours over two days before reaching its
verdict the suspend case revolved around
his september meeting with 2016 meeting
with james baker a friend who was the
fbi's general counsel suspend passed
along a tip that led to a four-month fbi
inquiry into a possible internet back
channel between the trump organization
and kremlin-linked alpha bank both
companies denied the claim and the fbi
didn't find any improper links and we
learned
from testimony that hillary clinton
signed off on it that many high-powered
uh high-profile democrats were deeply
involved in this the story was complete
bs but
apparently the fbi already knew so it
was a waste of everyone's time if this
is all durham has i can't say i'm
surprised but maybe something else will
happen i would be surprised if there's
any accountability what i find
fascinating is that you have people
who spread a a lie which cost the
federal government
what was it 50 million 35 million for
the mueller investigation
they're they they obvious this this guy
misrepresents who he's working with
claiming i believe that
he was claiming he wasn't working with
any campaign but he was working for the
clinton campaign
he no problem but what about
peter navarro right now being subpoenaed
to testify before the grand jury threats
of of putting him in jail like steve
bannon if they don't if they don't come
and testify
i hate to say it
double standard yeah right well look
it's not just that it was a waste of
everyone's time it was actually an
attempted insurrection the purpose was
to remove a democratically elected
president from the office the people of
this nation decided he should have
through the legal process
it was uh it was a political
insurrection attempt absolutely yeah
yeah i think anyone involved in that in
this we should we should file some 14th
amendment lawsuits seriously about their
eligibility to run for office seriously
seriously i mean none of those people
should still have a job that is i mean
it's unbelievably heinous and of course
the media helped them long every single
step of the way i mentioned a poll on
the show the other day when they pulled
democratic voters they found 50 percent
of them believed russia literally hacked
voting machines in the united states and
changed the votes that's how paranoid
people got over this in 2016 they
thought that happened in 2016. yeah
that's what they believed happened in
the 2016 election and no one got banned
from big tech no one was told that that
was a conspiracy theory they couldn't
spread no one had their life destroyed
over quite the opposite yeah exactly one
awards promoted they want awards for it
exactly and so one thing i find a little
bit interesting
is that when
the the previous president
was accused of some sort of election
fraud we investigated the president when
this president was accused of the same
thing we investigated the people
accusing him
yes yeah and everybody was insane who
believed that that was a any possibility
whatsoever that joe biden didn't get 81
million votes legit you're not allowed
to say that you're not allowed to to
question the narrative the the official
news stories but again in 2016 i mean
you still have people saying these
things online and i i i've got some
questions for for google and youtube
you've got people on youtube right now
that will say that they believed the
russian narrative and all that stuff but
that's okay because the new york times
said so right so they're allowed to say
that but if you're a trump supporter and
you say something about 2020 you're gone
you're allowed to question it like
because like for instance dominion
private company tallying votes in in
private we don't know what they did and
that's the problem in my eyes i question
what did they do but making claims about
it is where things start to get tricky
when it comes to social media
administration think about this in the
trump fraud narrative people were
spreading this
admittedly ridiculous story about
servers in germany and like a cia
shootout and all that stuff and they
were like what's going on and it's like
where this stuff come from and then you
have
donald trump running a secret server
with a german bank because he was an
asset of vladimir putin since the 1980s
and i'm like dude
you actually and i think it was jonathan
chait is his name who said donald trump
may be a a soviet asset he said donald
trump may have been a russian asset
since the 80s and i'm like that was the
soviet union dude like he's he's still a
part of whatever is going on yeah him
and tulsi gabbard and that and that was
mainstream that was msnbc that was new
york mag totally acceptable to say and
then a bunch of people with maga hats on
said something equally as absurd and
they were like wow look at those crazy
people look what they believe i don't i
don't see how we hold this country
together man but well but i think it
goes beyond elections too because to
your point about you know not being
allowed to question something i mean
they went so far with this as to name it
they call it the big lie and anybody who
questions this they're questioning the
big lie and their whole point is that
well it's it's too dangerous and it's
too destabilizing to allow people to
question the election look look what
could happen to society if they do
meanwhile these are the same people who
throughout the entire year of 2020 went
on tv night after night after night
telling black people that they're not
safe to walk to their mailbox because a
police officer will come and shoot them
encouraging every single night these
riots that were happening all across the
country but that's not a big lie we're
not questioning that there are fbi
statistics that we can look at and see
this is not a legitimate problem in this
country the way it's being portrayed by
the media but that's fine to say every
single night while people are getting
killed and neighborhoods are burning to
the ground this is why i often say that
the two factions aren't really left or
right it's do you believe the lie the
mainstream media or do you challenge the
mainstream media do you believe the
official narrative or do you question
the official narrative that's it
you know earlier you asked me if i was a
conservative yet or something like that
do i get conservative yet and i was like
no i don't think so i i think it doesn't
matter your politic your political
positions are it matters if you if you
believe the lies
right
yeah but you're one of i think the most
sort of high-profile transitioners that
we have seen transitioners yeah we've
you've been transitioning testosterone
what issues have i changed on in the
past 10 years i don't know about issues
but i just i know that my
uh
my experience sort of following you was
that you were sort of a well-known
podcaster who tended to have what i
think a lot of people thought were
left-wing values
i became aware of you mostly because i
had started to walk away and people kept
saying tim poole's talking about walk
away tim pool's talking about walkway
and it seemed at the time like when you
were first talking about me that you
maybe didn't like me that much or what i
was doing or you're just like oh my god
like look what's happening in society
and that's why britain is tracking this
walk away is taking off and stuff and
now you're
you kind of seem like a walk away to me
and now but walkways it's not about
becoming conservative right right yeah i
i i supported democrats in 2020 in the
primary tulsi gabbard and andrew yang am
i screaming yeah you're screaming man no
you're good you're fine my ears are
bleeding
but uh i ended up laughing for trump
turning it down
tulsi and tulsi and yang i support in
the process okay so the russian assets
basically oh yeah yang unbelievable i
don't know no i don't know about yang
tulsi was definitely called a russian
asset by hillary isn't that nuts they
were like no we need to we need a woman
of color in this election and then it's
like we need tulsi gabbard off the stage
she's like a hawaiian her skin is you
know like she's off i don't know what
kind of thing she's like they're like
some people of color are more people of
color than other people of color that's
right based on their opinions of course
well it was basically
you know they they they were uh grooming
tulsi gabbard to be this big democrat
player and then she she
she turned on him clinton yeah supported
bernie sanders and then i'm just
imagining you know you know all of these
top-level democrats like debbie
wasserman schultz faints and then
hillary catches her and she's fanning
her like oh oh dulce what have you done
and that's and then they were just like
she's out get rid of her yeah well she
really let camelot have it too
that was great that was so good yeah
yeah ripped her she shot back at hillary
pretty uh decently too
called her queen of the warmongers
that's right fantastic that was 2019
right yeah
regarding walking away brandon what
you're saying i do think of it as like
walking away from believing the tv when
i when i am told things like when
hillary's emails got leaked to uh
wikileaks and i started reading about
her dealings with you know sydney
blumenthal his company osprey global
solutions moving them into libya and
wanting to set up an arms dealership in
libya basically like gun running that
was like
it was hard to get people to believe it
and it was shocking that people didn't
believe it because it was in her emails
to sydney and her assistants and things
like that but at the same time i could
no longer tolerate it i can't live a lie
so i had no choice but to walk away from
that garbage
that consumptory garbage
trying to eat everything in its path as
soon as you i i i just think i'll go i
don't know i was just gonna say i don't
know if you uh know the scene but one
thing i learned from my television is if
someone did something really bad and
they get caught if the person who caught
them is bad that means they didn't do
the bad thing that's right
oh yeah yeah yeah that makes perfect
yeah exactly yeah turns out it was a
bunch of big bad russians or something
like that and then it
that if a person does a bad thing and
the president questions the bad thing
and asks for an investigation it's
actually the president who did the bad
thing yeah it's true yeah that's a fact
and that's always true no matter who the
president
down calm down if is president if the
president's name starts with a t-r-u-m-p
and ends with t-r-u-m-p got it always
bad right yeah yeah the ukraine stuff i
i is the most mind-warping crazy like
you have a video of joe biden saying
quid pro quo joe biden literally on
video laughing about he tried to halt us
congressionally approved aid to ukraine
unless he got a personal favor
and they're like you can't do this and
he goes call the president see what he
says and then trump was like wow that
looks like a you know something what's
up with that and they were like trump
did it
it's like it's like imagine being in an
elevator and then you fart and then tell
the other guy that it was them
like that's what they were doing then
you spent three years investigating no
no then who farted it was definitely him
the elevator opens up and there's a
crowd of people standing in front of and
they go oh what was that and you see
biden going
and they're like it was clearly him it's
on video and that but wait
it was trump trump was the one who did
the bad thing after all that's actually
what they did joe biden
threatened the the president of ukraine
with withholding approved aid unless
they did him a personal favor yes
and but but it was the it was the policy
of the united states at the time it's
like no no look joe biden didn't have
the authority to supersede
uh approved aid that's what they said
when when trump said
that
you know look into this they said trump
has no has no right to to block aid to
ukraine it's like that's what he was
calling saying joe biden was doing so
why are you not yelling about joe biden
doing it because
the media it's all just
it's a puppet show man but that's the
ultimate gaslighting what you're
describing right now and if i think that
if people on the left
who are still subscribing to
to the left like i used to before i
walked away could actually see it
um
they're so brazen about accusing other
people doing the exact things that
they're actually doing i mean that is
like the the breadcrumb chrome trail
right there if people could see it like
if the democrats are accusing somebody
of doing it
automatically they're doing it right now
investigate investigate but the people
don't see it you know why i don't call
it the left is because in 2006 it was
the republicans it was george bush and
cheney if you question the 911 narrative
and the war in iraq you were like all of
a sudden an outcast and a conspiracy
theorist and then it was like bill
crystal the war advisor he also he's a
democrat now he's with hillary clinton
right it's so weird so there's this is
war party that is like unaffiliated and
and it's like they're the one making the
media tell you the accomplishment but
that's a question that i actually wanted
to ask all you guys when you were
talking a second ago about like media
narratives i i get asked this all the
time as somebody who left the left and i
ended up becoming a republican
um
in my opinion you know i used to hate
fox news as a liberal i used to think
fox news was everything that they said
was a lie and some sort of conspiracy
theory and that they were doling out
misinformation
now you know i've spent a lot of time
watching fox news over the last four or
five years and i don't feel that way
anymore i do believe that they are
absolutely biased i think they
absolutely have a point of view that
they're trying to push but i don't see
examples of them blatantly lying and
creating misinformation and creating
completely false stories but i do see
that from left-wing media all the time
so
do you think it's equal because i get
asked this question all the time people
are like oh well fox news does that too
do you do you think they do msnbc is
owned by comcast which is owned by
blackrock i don't know how deep it goes
on fox's end uh i think fox what is it
fox 20th century fox is owned by disney
at this point does what's the last news
owned by fox news is is i think it's
still news corp right i don't know how
deep blackrock has their temperatures
fox doesn't play
you know
it's crazy that we're at this point
where
i used to i i was talking about that i
used to watch cnn nice to have it on all
the time and then one day it was just a
trump panel and i was like is it isn't
something happening and i turn on fox
news and they're like riots erupt in
iran and i was like oh wow i'm watching
video footage of these riots and then
later there's like a big storm i turn on
cnn and there's a panel talking about
trump and then i change the channel and
it's fox and they're like prepare for
the storm big storm's coming here's what
people are saying and i was just like
cnn is not news
it is it you know what i think
jeff zucker was a reality tv guy
and so he approached cnn
actually let me let me stop before
saying cnn i'll tell you exactly what
what i experienced with fusion this was
the abc news univision joint venture
i leave vice i joined fusion
and for the first six to eight months
they were like we're going to do news
we they had they had a show about drug
cartels and like federal agents and
mexican federal agents going after them
and then one day they were just like
we're changing things up they hired a
new editor-in-chief
whose twitter profile was down with
whiteness and he's like a white guy and
it was a black fist and i was told that
they were shifting into mission-driven
storytelling
and then i was told that because young
people are progressive that's what
they're going after
they want to target young people and
young people are progressive so that's
the narrative that they're pursuing
so all of a sudden there was this shift
where it was like tell the truth to
side with the audience
tell them what they want to hear right
and that's what happened there you go
and that was that was 2014
right the idea i think and then cnn
obviously adopts a similar dealer right
the cnn and all these media outlets
adopted the exact same thing they you
know look look at this show
we're not the most tribal show but
there's tribalism entrenched in what we
do of course because everybody is got a
perspective we're clearly in the
right-wing sphere of influence whatever
you want to call it including
libertarians conservatives and
post-liberals we uh have direct
disagreements with establishment media
establishment personalities and the
leftists who outright support them
so that's there
but if you if you take a look at the
prominent right-wing voices they're like
middle of the road if you take a look at
the left they're hard left
pro-establishment right so when you have
you have the left claiming and i mean
the legit left the socialists joe
biden's bad we can't support him
we all voted for him and we think you
should vote for him too like that was
the funniest thing watching these
socialists be like
we don't like joe biden but you have to
vote for him and i was like this dude is
the epitome he's he's like he's like
goldman sachs you know big banker elite
corporate neocon neolib for what reason
would any leftist support that i guess
because they're fascists or whatever no
they don't have principles they
literally do not have principles what's
most important to them is trying to
establish a specific social order and
however they have to get their hands
dirty along the way they're willing to
as long as they end up getting the
pieces in the right place eventually and
this is interesting because uh
you you asked me before the show if i
was conservative now
and you know talking about walking away
and i said no i don't think so i think
the issue is just as i mentioned a
moment ago if you believe the lies or
not if you if you trust the narrative
from the establishment or you question
it is what really separates the spheres
of influence yeah so when you see
uh we did this thing with uh ground.news
you can look up someone's news
consumption bias
invariably
you pull up a left-wing personality and
it'll say all of like 80 or 90 of their
news consumption is left-wing sources
you pull up people like you know michael
malus or me
and it says
a balance of left right and center mine
i think is 55 left-wing sources then
like 20 percent center and the rest is
right i think mine was 30 or 35. but
then a lot of conservative personalities
are like 60 conservative and then like
15 and 15 of centrist or left-wing but
they have way more left-wing news in
their diet than the left has the other
way around so you'll you'll see that
then what happens is we bring someone on
the show
this like former conservative guy
and he outright told me the joe biden
quid pro quo thing didn't happen i
mentioned i was like so you get joe
biden saying you know sob the guy got
fired that didn't happen and he like
smirks and i was like he said like he
couldn't let that stand or something
yeah yeah yeah that's right further than
that like i can't let that say that
didn't happen and i was like yes it did
and he's like no no it didn't i was like
okay and i pulled the video up i'm like
here's a video watch it and he was like
oh
i'm like and like what are you serious
you didn't google it you just heard it
you thought it was true that's the thing
man
the uh the covington kid stuff
i don't just believe it people are like
you got to see this man people on the
right were critical of them and i was
like what happened and we have a lot of
that going on right now like there was
that story of that uh that young young
girl in the school who was sexually
assaulted in loudoun county and everyone
on the right is just saying it was a
trans person and i'm like that was never
part of the story they just started
saying that and i'm like if you actually
look it up the kid never said they were
trans at least that's my that's my
understanding having read the story i
was like if someone says something
happened i don't care from the left or
right i'm going to read it it turns out
reality has a conservative bias
at least in my investigation and my
doing of journalism and fact checking
that's what i found
the left lies about everything
should we do the list again
yeah russia gate ukraine gate uh justice
malettes michael brown ahmed arbury what
are we missing trayvon martin wow the
media actually george
oh yeah joe biden's whole campaign oh
yeah lies nonstop yeah and then they and
then the left tries to talk about the
republicans and i'm like yeah who's
praising mitch mcconnell right now
right i don't know anybody who's
actively in politics like that's a great
guy i'm really a big fan of him but what
is he even saying in terms of facts
nothing
so
i don't consider myself conservative i
consider myself someone who is
interested in what's true and what's
real you said something earlier that's
interesting because i think a lot of
people problem they're having is when
they hear something that they don't
necessarily want to believe they just
immediately say that's not real no
but a good a strong mind is capable of
tending an idea without believing it or
disbelieving it just allowing it to
exist and considering it well what you
just described is literally the
experience that i had that created the
sort of epiphany sorry that created sort
of the epiphany for me that
um
began the journey of me walking away
because it's uh
not to bore anybody
um
after trump got elected you know i had
voted for hillary i was devastated and
um i was really acting out about it i
was really angry and one of the things
that i said was in january of 2017 so he
was a was around the time he was about
to take office i went on facebook and i
blasted conservatives in this post where
i just said you know i'll never be able
to understand how anyone could vote for
a man who is capable of standing before
a cheering crowd and mocking a
reporter's disability do you remember
that one yeah and that's when um
somebody that i knew um she was my
babysitter when i was kid this woman
diane she was always a conservative but
she reached out to me privately on
facebook with this video called
debunking the trump mock disabled
reporter and she was like you know i'm
just wondering have you seen this you
know i'm not i'm not trying to start a
fight with you but i remember my
instinct when i just reading the title
of the video i was so enraged that she
would try that anyone would try to
debunk that he did that because i was
like but i saw it i saw it with my own
eyes i know he did it i cnn told me he
did it and um then i decided
then i decided to watch the video
because i um
i thought to myself well it's going to
be really clear that this is like
right-wing propaganda and fox news
brainwashing so then i can tell her how
stupid she is for falling for it and i
watched it and i it was like i almost
dissociated from my body because my
brain was like screaming at me like oh
my god i don't think he mocked that
reporter's disability
but my heart was like going yeah but we
hate him but we hate him but we hate him
and i had to watch it four times before
i could reconcile within myself that i
would i was wrong and but then it took
me at least another week or two before i
was able to go back to diane that woman
and be like okay i i
i may be changing my mind about this one
thing not about trump but about this one
incident but that
that set me down the road of trying to
figure out what was going on with the
media and i want well i just want to
make a point here i remember that story
as well and when i heard it i didn't
look too deeply into it i thought maybe
i mean i think it's horrible if he said
something like that of course it turned
out to be fake news because basically
everything they say turns out to be fake
news but even so even if he had done
something as horrible as mock somebody
with a disability because of hillary
clinton there are slave markets back in
libya she completely decimated a country
and i'm sorry but
that's worse
that is so much worse even if trump
actually did it which he didn't
it is worse to destroy an entire country
to the point where slavery has returned
to the region so i didn't i didn't vote
in 2016 because i was just like are you
kidding me donald trump and hillary
clinton i heard what trump was saying
but i was like please i've heard this
all before it's the back and forth
nonsense but i i didn't think it'd be
real hilarious if trump ended up winning
just because it's trump and then when
hillary lost it was just so hilarious
but my so um when it came to joe biden
versus trump
i i was i was flabbergasted at the
leftists who were like we're going to
vote for joe biden and i was like
joe biden was the vice president under
barack obama the national defense
authorization act indefinite detention
provisions expansion of the war in the
middle east expansion of drone strikes
the bombing of civilians and then saying
oh but they're military age males the
extrajudicial assassination of american
citizens and i was like
you screamed that george w bush was
hitler and now you've got the vice
president of a guy who killed american
citizens without charge or trial i'm
voting for trump because
what
he he was he would no new wars there
were there were more drone strikes as we
were pulling troops i was like okay look
trump's not that bad right i was like
you can i hear all the complaints left
makes about him i think his attitude his
his character was like unbecoming of a
presidential office all that stuff
matters to a lot of people decorum does
matter but for me i'm like it matters
relatively little compared to a booming
economy in 2019 i don't blame him for
covet i don't blame joe biden for coven
but then looking at joe biden in the
election and i was like if that guy gets
elected we'll be right back in syria
we're gonna have we're gonna have new
war mark my words it is gonna get worse
and donald trump had some good second
term policy positions so i said okay
what do we get
wow man
let i wanna make sure everybody hears
this when you go to the gas pump and you
see that little joe biden that says i
did that that's not a joke joe biden
shut down keystone joe biden introduced
new regulations on gas he banned uh he
put he put a freeze on oil and gases on
federal land there's a lot he's done we
had that video from hollywood he goes
through all of the policies and you know
why joe biden did it climate change
now i'm not i'm not making a moral
statement on climate change i think
pollution and all the stuff is really
really bad i think there are issues with
these massive population centers
overpopulating or polluting
but if you are wondering why your gas
prices are high it is because the people
who are scared about climate change are
enacting policies specifically because
of climate change they are saying they
are doing it and it's causing economic
crises
if you're a co if you're cool with that
because you think climate change is bad
well just admit it and that that's fine
i'm not issuing a moral statement but
joe biden literally did this because of
climate change and now we've got reports
that farms are being paid out to farm
they're being paid to build solar farms
instead
i mean it's very obvious what they're
doing just not telling people but that's
the reason if you're a climate change
activist be proud those high gas prices
mean less people will drive and lower
carbon emissions and if you're a middle
american working class person who's
struggling to pay your bills that's why
it's happening
but do you
do you i honestly do you feel like your
words will resonate with these people i
mean this kind of goes back to the
conversation you i were having before
the show i mean like
if if trump were to run again are enough
people getting it
that it actually would make a difference
because i actually believe
that a lot of people on the left are
willing to pay six dollars a gallon for
gas or more if they believe that we
don't have hitler in office again well
i just want to say this i mean your
former babysitter had faith that she
could reach you right and it worked
right it worked when i was faced with
the realization that something that i
okay here's the thing
i learned that my
uh my feelings were being manipulated by
the people that i trusted i trusted cnn
i thought that they were honest and i
hated people like donald trump and i
hated people like republicans because i
thought that they were bad people i
thought they were people that did things
like make fun of disabled people and
everyone laughs and cheers but as it
turns out
to me it's i say this all the time you
know and as a gay person i always say
this like the left will pretend like
they're the they're the people that care
about black people and brown people and
lgbt people and all this stuff but the
thing is they're actually lying and
manipulating and exploiting all of these
people to get them to think the way they
want them to think and behave and vote
the way that they want them to vote
i will any day of the week take the
enemy that will look into my eyes and
say i don't like gay people i do i just
like i'll never be down with you i don't
like you then the person who says no no
i'm your friend i'm on your side i'm
here to protect you but they're actually
lying to me and manipulating me and
that's what i discovered through that
that i experienced
i want to answer i want to answer what
you're asking about but put attacking
that yeah what i want to say is we are
people getting the message it depends on
how you all at home are delivering the
message
if you have someone who is deep blue
vote blue no matter who going to them
and being like it's your fault that gas
prices are so high because joe biden and
all and these climate not gonna work
you can do two things
me i prefer the middle of the road
straightforward approach where when i'm
talking with someone who i know might
not agree i'll just be like
man you see those gas prices and they'll
go yeah dude i'll be like that's crazy
what is it it's like six bucks in
pennsylvania geez it's like almost up
upwards of eight dollars in some parts
of california but hey man look what we
what we're seeing joe biden he wants to
fight climate change you know so they
want to shut down keystone pipeline
because they don't want the oil moving
through and then you get speculation
which drives prices i mean uh
russia all stuff plays a role but these
prices were skyrocketing before that so
look i mean if you guys want to be
serious about climate change this is
what happens that is an effective
message they might say
yeah i get it that's bad and i'm
suffering because of it or you can do
the even more manipulative
which is you see gas prices
eight bucks a gallon in california bro
high five you know this means it means
no one's driving good they shouldn't be
driving anyway if they can't afford
electric cars
these people think oh i can come out and
talk about climate change but they do
nothing they keep eating they keep
guzzling they keep flushing their
toilets they take half an hour showers
during droughts good i hope they cry
every time they see that eight dollar
per gallon price and that's joe biden
who did that joe biden sent a strong
message to these american gluttons who
are burning through carbon every single
day we will end climate change mark my
words and joe biden will do it and then
regular people are going to be like that
was psychotic that's what you say
in the intersection before you drive up
in your tesla to the guy next to it
so so that's the more manipulative
approach where you make someone be like
that's a crazy position i don't want gas
prices this high i'm not a fan of that
but that is you know i mean it's it's
it's it's like you have to go there it's
like black propaganda it's like shocking
someone with you know what's going on
but i mean i got to be honest you don't
even need to do that because maybe just
show them a video of someone you know at
like the dsa convention where they were
like my name's john he him can people
stop clicking their pens because it's
driving my anxiety and then and then
someone gets them go stop saying guys
and then they're all yelling i'm like
just show them show them that video but
but in all reality the way to
effectively give someone the message is
just to be polite about it and say
joe biden said he wanted to fight
climate change so he passed some
regulations that caused the hiccups in
the in the energy sector he's not
responsible for all of the escalation of
gas prices but he played a big role i
mean a year before he came into office
gas was like two bucks now it's at like
four to five bucks so i mean it's
obvious that you know climate change
policy they also kind of stopped playing
the game of trying to change people's
minds in one
conversation we play more of the
chipping away with just honesty and
kindness and listening to them because
they'll you know they're probably not
completely wrong about everything anyway
so it's nice to hear that that's a good
point well no i mean there's an old
saying in every heresy there's a kernel
of truth i mean people believe things
because there is like some shred of
goodness there that they're trying to
scrape at and if you can figure out what
that little kernel of goodness is you
can show them the truth in how it really
fully embodies that i'm not saying it
always works well look what i am saying
i i agree with what ian is saying that
there is there is something there about
like trying to figure now obviously
we have people in this culture who are
like completely bad faith actors or
totally morally depraved but i'm saying
like someone you might meet in your
everyday life who could be persuadable
so yeah i think it's it's it's the left
and not the right
right uh this is just reality the right
has post liberals these are people who
are the walk away people yeah they're
still very politically liberal a lot of
issues but they have aligned themselves
now with republicans pew research showed
that what are they called the stressed
sideliners lean right on political
issues and it's probably because the
left keeps moving further and further
left like that elon musk meme so when
you see uh there's one thing right now
uh about me because i'm i'm i'm staunch
2a people are wondering what positions
i've changed on i went from
i think guns are cool maybe we can have
some you know simple gun reforms that
might make everybody happy too not all
guns like guns are legal two-way if
you've got a problem you gotta change
the constitution
so i said in on an episode that the
second amendment protects the right to
keep and bear nuclear arms and
biological arms but i'm not wrong
now just because second amendment
protects it doesn't mean it's legal you
can do it or you should be able to do it
so they take a clip of me cut out the
context where i'm like people should
have people have the right to have nukes
and and ian's like in biological goblins
i'm like absolutely and then they cut up
the part where i'm like that doesn't
mean they should it means that when the
second amendment was codified in the
constitution people had warships that
could flatten coastal cities and the
founding fathers knew that and were like
you can have it the right to keep in
bear and so there's a lot of sophistry
in the second amendment argument where
they say like but a well-regulated
militia that has nothing to do with what
the actual prescription of the second
amendment is they're saying because of
this need the people have a right to
keep and bear arms and arms means arms
does it say accept nuclear in the second
amendment it doesn't should it perhaps
it should and that's something we will
need to change but that's that's
something i i've changed on for sure now
what happens is
in this whole issue they're sharing that
clip out of context and then they create
fake context around it yeah and so after
they post that clip the morsel of truth
sheamus mentioned they then will add
something like and after this tim said
this which i didn't say and then people
believe it because they saw a video and
then saw someone telling them the story
someone will say tim poole thinks
everyone should have a nuclear weapon
because he wants humanity to be wiped
out here's the video here's proof and
then people go wow then they say tim
poole also claims that china
manufactured kovid to wipe out white
people or something like that which is
like something they're actually trying
to claim and these are high-profile
left-wing accounts that's why i say when
you look at the right they
reality has a conservative bias at least
for now maybe it'll change in 10 years
what do you mean what does that mean
exactly
it means
so uh stephen colbert the famous quote
reality has a liberal bias
and what the point he was making i guess
was that the liberal media as
conservatives call it tends to be true
and they're fake news therefore reality
must have a liberal bias
the reality is today if you're talking
to a conservative personality ben
shapiro great example if you listen to
ben shapiro you are
99 of the time gonna hear the absolute
truth to the best of his ability i don't
mean like the dude is omniscient but
he's going to be like we got a new
report coming up in the new york times
that says yeah you have a new repair for
the new times right this is what it says
this is why they're absolutely wrong but
he will tell you what they're saying jan
cucumber the young turks will just say
nonsense right yeah and if you if you
watch his show
this is why you know you watch the young
turks they'll just say things that are
plum not true or they'll just make
dramatic personalized like personal
arguments that have nothing to do with
the issues ben shapiro uh he told us
he's like i don't debate people i have
discussions with them but they're you
know the left will constantly be arguing
so what do they do the video that goes
viral of ben shapiro is some kid being
like well
you can't please your wife
and then the left is like oh and they'll
high five each other and i'm like okay
why would why would anyone want to be
associated with that and what does that
have to do with the with the principled
arguments we're having thus
you talk to someone on the right you'll
end up hearing closer to the truth than
the left
yeah i think i agree with that it's only
because this liberal economic order has
its fangs in the neck of the american
citizen i want to talk about walking
away we have this story from ap
some democrats voting in gop primaries
to block trump picks
they going to say diane murray struggled
with her decision all the way up to the
election day but when the time came the
54 year old can we pull this up yes
sorry sir the uh 54 year old georgia
democrat cast a ballot in last week's
republican primary for secretary of
state brad raffensberger while state law
allowed her to participate in either
party's primary said it felt like a
violation of her core values to vote for
the republican but it had to be done she
decided to prevent donald trump backed
election denier from becoming the
battleground state election chief quote
i feel strongly that our democracy is at
risk and that people who are holding up
the big lie as we call it are holding on
to the former president's uh president
are dangerous to our democracy okay blah
blah blah blah blah
there was data that came out that showed
in georgia seven percent
of the republican primary votes were
former democrats
and the media then came out and started
saying things like this oh this is this
this is democrats trying to sabotage
trump and i'm like that's a really bad
thing to say even if it's true that the
will of the people is being subverted by
people who are trying to uh sabotage a
primary
but i don't believe it's true
i don't i don't believe that seven
percent we're talking about a hundred
thousand people we're all like we're
democrats but we're gonna vote the
republican race to ruin trump's chances
is it bad that i absolutely believe it
you do believe that a hundred thousand
people who voted did it because they
hate trump i
believe it's possible i didn't say it's
not possible yeah i believe that it is
just extremely unlikely and the reality
is it's people who are like the economy
is in the gutter
the there's a food shortage a fuel
shortage and i'm paying five bucks a
gallon for gas i'm vote republican yeah
well look i mean money talks and it
speaks much more eloquently and
effectively than any rhetoric people
have to throw what six bucks into the
pump to get a gallon of gas yeah they're
probably not going to vote for more of
the same i'll i'll to your point though
it would be foolish of any republican
conservative right wing whatever you
want to call it to ignore this story 100
because rest assured it may come
election time and you're like we got in
the bag look at the turnout from the
republican primaries record-breaking and
then all of a sudden there's a surge in
democrat votes because they really were
trying to sabotage you
i think it's absolutely possible that
this is an organized effort to get in
and sabotage things i do think it can
happen in the numbers that you just
described i think when you said earlier
that these people have no principles
this could absolutely be an example of
just that but wait hold on my question
for you is
i understand the the state of the
country and the the price of gas
inflation everything pushing people over
to the right or even making the decision
oh my god i'm going to vote republican
even though i've never done that my
entire life but to switch parties and
vote in primaries i'm not so sure that's
a good point there's but i think maybe a
lot of people just don't understand what
the primaries are but but i do think
it's a good point but i will say this in
2018 about 600 000 people voted in the
republican primary
in the in the primary in 2022 it was 1.1
million
they estimated only about 7 were former
democrats this means that the
republicans are just seeing a surge in
new voters
that says a lot
so who wants
sorry who wants these new voters if
they're coming if you still just hate
trump
okay so it's uh you know i still hate
trump as much as i ever did but i hate
how expensive gas is so i'm going to
become a republican and vote against any
of the pro-trump people
you're not a republican right you're
they're not right they don't know so
look we're politicos right we're we're
deeply entrenched in all the stuff the
regular person is probably sitting in
their living room and they're just like
they get or they come home from work and
they see their wife it's like how was
work and it's like honey man i don't
know how we're going to budget for this
i mean i just had to put 70 bucks in the
gas tank to get to work
we're not making enough money that's
just
this this this biden this these
democrats it's like well i'm voting
republican
they don't know what the primaries are
what they mean for the most part they
just know they get the thing in the mail
saying go vote and they're like i'm
voting republican but if this woman
represents uh some sort of like key
demographic of these people can we show
the quote again what she said yeah she
said
i feel strongly that democracy is at
risk and that people who are holding up
the big lie as we call it are holding on
to the former president are dangerous to
democracy
that is not just somebody who's like i
don't know how to budget for the month
and i don't really follow politics right
but this is one person
right but i'm just saying if she is
representative of the mentality of a lot
of these people making this this choice
so here's what they're saying they're
saying an ap analysis of early voting
from data from l2 found that more than
37 000 people who voted in georgia's
democrat primary two years ago cast
ballots in last week's republican
primary an unusually high number of
so-called crossover voters even taking
into account the limited sample of early
votes i just got to say in the absence
of evidence the solution that makes the
least amount of assumptions tends to be
the correct one and what we have seen
i mean i remember back in
2019 or 2020
we had the c-span video
where
people were just calling being like i
have voted democrat for 20 years and i
am sick to my stomach of this i'm voting
republican with these huge stories i
mean you're mr walk away how many people
have you met who walked away we had nine
million people in 2016 switch from
democrats to republicans
the simple solution is
most people are just voting republican
because they're sick of the democratic
party
well i can tell you that in the
testimonials that we had before facebook
banned our group in 2021 uh the videos
and the the written testimonials were
all people saying
that they had an awakening that
that i'd say the key thing that most
people had in common was an awakening
awakening that they were being lied to
manipulated and exploited and that that
awakening
led them to see
that trump what they understood why
trump was a
salvation to a lot of people and they
even considered i mean they said i'm
gonna vote for trump so it wasn't like
i'm gonna go you know hold my nose and
vote for trump this time or i'm becoming
a republican but i i'm just not going to
vote for the president i mean they were
enthusiastic about trump all these
people walking the majority of these
people
it wasn't this woman right it's a good
point though that why are they voting in
the primary i think well i think part of
the reason they liked him so much is
because in a sense they're getting out
of an abusive relationship with a really
terrible ex and he's talking smack to
him all the time and they're like you
know what i kind of like this guy yeah
i don't know what do you think ian do
you think these are these are democrats
sabotaging do you think it's genuine
uh yeah there's probably some people
that are gonna sign up for the other
party to try and sabotage it but i think
a lot of people are disenfranchised with
the democratic i mean biden's near
demented at this state it's really hard
to watch him yeah i'm very gracious
about saying coming out and being like
dementia alzheimer's like i'm not a
doctor so but it seems that way and i
mean the hillary clinton email thing was
insane the way bernie sanders got
screwed over two two elections in a row
cycles let me let me ask you this way
ian
if
i
made you an offer
a wager as it were
for one dollar
you could bet that biden is either
suffering from severe dementia or he's
not
and if you are right you would win 1 000
which one would you like
wait wait i should probably put it the
other way around what i'm trying to say
my my point i love the man man i want to
help him if you had to wager a thousand
bucks and you could win a thousand bucks
you know which one are you gonna battle
give me a thousand to one odds whatever
you could bet me a dollar for a dollar
i'd still say if he has dementia i don't
know that's fine but that's my guess
he shuffles his feet and looks at the
ground when he walks no one is going to
risk any amount of money like
like except for our entire economy
i guess 80
10 years ago and then put on a video
from 10 weeks ago and it's like two
different people it's it's hot terrified
he's in charge of the military yeah but
sheamus
a lot of people in 2020 we had we had
coveted lockdown it was bad for a lot of
people and they said we need change this
was trump's leadership
they they probably thought it's going to
be like obama all over again those years
oh man they're remembering being in
college or you know back in the good old
days and i was like i remember we used
to go to the bar and play wii sports you
know like i got to vote for joe biden
bring back the obama era and now we
bring back flip phones vote for him
remember that
story i was trying to talk to my mother
about the tara read story because she
didn't really know it she's getting had
been getting a lot of info from cnn and
it's like no well i mean this girl i
don't know credibly accused that's a
funny buzz word incredibly but i mean
she was like he pushed me up against the
wall in the middle of the building
capitol building wherever they were and
he did unspeakable things yes horrific
yeah and she worked for him she was like
one of his aides and like that just got
pushed under the road totally pushed
under the rug i'm oh lifting the rug up
so you can look at it tara reid look at
her name it's r-e-a-d-e by the way joe
biden sniffs little girls like this is
not even up for a debate there's videos
of him doing it and they don't talk
about it isn't that so bizarre that
that's just not even disgusting because
a man has dementia and he sniffs
children constantly it's not like a
one-off thing i think here's the thing
now i know you guys are going to call me
crazy and maybe you know i thought
conservatives were against canceled
culture i can't believe he's about to
say this i think if you sniff one child
in public once your career should be up
joe biden has repeatedly sniffed
children
the first time he did it they should
have walked him off stage and says let's
not do that again
regarding his leg hair being touched by
the kids in the pool that he was telling
us about i got it
i think maybe that it was like the kids
were like oh it's a sea monster because
the hair was real long and he was like
ah you know the grandkids are so
probably not insidious i love when the
media runs these stories where they're
alike conservatives believe in
conspiracy theories about a cabal of
pedos and all that and i'm like listen
listen
i think those conspiracy theories are
pretty nuts but it's not helping your
case that joe biden is sniffing children
right on stage in front of in front of
the press and you're angry at bills that
want to prevent sexual education for
kindergartners through third grade
you're like oh no this is the hill we
want to die on and not just that bills
that say you can't have secret
conversations with children about sex
that you tell them knox reports or their
parents
says
it's not just that these things are
happening it's that the media is either
pretending they're not happening or when
they do talk about it they try to
completely twist the story and gaslight
you into believing that you're the crazy
one for being against these these
unspeakable things
you know that song institutionalized by
suicidal tendencies i'm not crazy
institution yeah we need to make a
modern version of that a cover what's
about the media and it's like i turn on
the tv i turn on cnn you know i'm like
trying to figure out what's going on in
the world and they tell me you know joe
biden didn't collude with the ukrainian
president to protect his son's business
and i'm like yo but there's video of him
saying it and they're just like and then
my mom comes in you know that song
so that sounds great it's funny one
thing i used to do um
i was i was doing a cartoon a while ago
about the uh scandal with ole joe biden
withholding funds from ukraine so that
they would uh
do his bidding basically and back off
the investigation into the the company
his son was working for yeah burisma and
i i was like well you know what it's
always good to get the other perspective
i don't want to spread misinformation if
i'm wrong about this so i looked up to
see what like the fact checkers were
saying because usually what they'll do
is gather all of what the left perceives
to be as the strongest arguments against
a conservative statement or position
and
i'm not kidding you the fact check i
read said well
it was actually obama administration
policy so it's mostly false to say that
joe biden was doing this for his own
goals or his own motives it's like what
he's the vice president of the
administration
they said that it was
obama's administration's policy to go
blackmail the ukrainian government yeah
yeah yeah
yes
yeah i don't know i'd like to you know
you know i was thinking it's interesting
imagine this is a while imagine anybody
willing to vote for joe biden at this
point that means they're like well the
economy is in the gutter gas prices have
shattered records consistently inflation
is shattering records consistently he
sniffs children and they want to take
away our right to keep and bear arms
like he is the epitome of a fascist and
who's just destroying everything and
they would prefer that for what reason
you just like very matter-of-factly
listed all of those things and it's like
that is insane that is actually
what is happening that is the president
of the united states right now i got the
feeling that people were so angry i
don't know if anger is the right word
but so disillusioned or didn't like
trump so much they're like i will vote
for poop over that guy you give me a
steaming pile of poop and i will vote
for it but i don't know if that's
because they're like diluted on drug
like psychoactive pharmaceuticals and
they don't feel like they don't
understand maybe they're just low iq
maybe people just aren't as smart as i'm
giving them credit for and they're
voting with their gut
instead of their
logic the average person you mean like
when you're talking about the people who
voted yeah it's a good question i mean
so
like time magazine came out and
published a part an article where they
basically admitted that in every single
way they possibly could legally they
orchestrated the election to ensure that
they would get a specific outcome and we
live in a culture where people have been
consistently trained
to always take the path of least
resistance and do whatever brings them
pleasure as opposed to what makes sense
and what that results in is people who
are just followers and will basically do
whatever the media tells them get upset
about the issues the media tells them to
be upset about and vote for the people
the media tells them to vote for i want
to pull this tweet from michael malus he
said no one wants to take away your guns
no one wants to shut down your business
no one wants lockdowns to continue more
than necessary no one is going to force
you to have a vaccine passport no one is
teaching your kids critical race theory
these are all just conspiracy theories
that's right
nobody wants to indoctrinate
indoctrinate your children that's right
yeah that's never happened before that's
crazy yeah
they don't have kids they have yours i
like that that he said uh they don't
it's not what does he say no one is
going to before all those statements
well said no one wants to yeah no one
wants to fill this in they didn't want
to you made them do it i used to joke
with my buddy matt and we'd be like it's
not that i hate you it's it's not that
you're an idiot that's not what i'm
saying you get it like you started off
with it's not that and then you just say
what you feel
[Laughter]
so you're not an idiot so brandon i want
to talk to you though okay uh
you you walked away you voted for trump
yes will you still vote for trump um
well uh i want to you know keep my
options open for whatever uh
i'm a big ron desantis fan
so
let's pull this up real quick we have
this from timcast.com trump and desantis
are now tied as 2024 front runners on
predict it so predict it of course is
you know people can
buy shares essentially who they think
they're going to win well what do you
think first
you want to keep your your options open
you said well all i mean is that i want
to
he has to announce i mean that's the
whole thing is he going to announce or
not i mean i think that most people
think that he is definitely um
so i mean if he announces and he's he if
he announces i don't think that anyone
can take him nor do i think that ron
desantis will even run if he announces
so in that scenario uh definitely i mean
would you vote for him if he if he runs
yes would you vote for him even if he
shot someone on fifth avenue
the real question uh probably yeah
honestly
i mean
but
you know i think that um
a lot of people are very excited about
desantis right now uh i definitely think
i don't like a lot of what i'm seeing on
the trump side in terms of the devotion
like i get it when he was in office i
even get it when he was running because
he was so different
uh i you know i think that he uh he got
it he understood the concerns of the
american people at a time then people
feel like america is being sold out and
they needed a hero
and i think that he was that hero you
know for for a really long time
but at this point
um because people i think are so
desperate about how the 2020 election
went and how things currently are in
this country
there are factions within the trump
community that are becoming cultish and
you're not allowed
you're not allowed to criticize him
you're not allowed to ask questions
you're not allowed to express a
disfavorable opinion about anything that
he does and then okay now we are
becoming the thing that the left has
said if that's what it's going to be i
don't want to be i will not be a part of
a cult so if i'm not allowed to
criticize trump or if i'm not allowed to
question decisions that he makes
like endorsing dr oz or
okay yeah but if i'm not allowed to say
that then then i am out because i'm not
gonna be a part of that culture no but
you can still vote for trump you know
like yeah i will i will but there's a
difference between going in and voting
for him and being really outspoken and
endorsing and you know i
i i think that i influenced a lot of
people to come around to him in 2020 for
sure you know the the the hardcore trump
supporters really do not like me because
i won't support trump's narrative on the
election fraud stuff because i just
think it's
look
i think the issue is you need to discuss
what happened in 2020
in a
methodical way
the problem is a lot of people put the
push these extreme stories about you
know servers in germany and watermarked
ballots i look forward to sitting down
with with former president trump because
we're we're planning on you know getting
an interview with them hopefully no
guarantees it's i'd be honored it'd be
an honor and a privilege um but i would
like to ask him mr president did you
watermark any ballots and when he says
no i'll be like okay see this is the
issue that youtube is banning people for
they're banning people for those wild
stories about
secret behind-the-scenes missions and
what needs to be expressed is that time
magazine ran an article saying the
shadow campaign to fortify the election
or to save the election and you talk
about how rules were changed about
election laws about universal mail and
voting and the process that took over a
year that resulted in a defeat
so donald trump can come out and say all
these things but if he says it in a way
where he's talking about
those things
then you've got no problem
the issue is there's a lot of people who
want to believe the craziest scenarios
because
they can't admit that people were
willing to vote for for joe biden
destroying this country because they
hated trump so much and i think
i think that's what happened i think
there's there's obvious bs that we saw
we saw videos there's uh bill barr said
there was fraud but just not enough of
it i think we saw unconstitutional
voting rules this is this this literally
happened in pennsylvania where a judge
ruled the voting law change was
unconstitutional but only after the fact
right those things that happened okay
like that would you focus on that stuff
and you stay away from the more
conspiratorial stuff now my point here
most people are referring to that stuff
and not the weird conspiracy stuff right
youtube will conflate all of it and the
media will conflate all of it so that
when you're trying to talk to people
they don't understand what you're trying
to say yeah it's like uh psychological
surgery where if you make a mistake the
patient will die and that's how the
sensors are treating this conversation
you have to be extremely
uh i guess accurate and um i don't know
there's other words for it but direct
and focused and intentional when you're
communicating about this election fraud
in general i mean it's a huge
conversation it's important conversation
but
the whole situation the whole question
around the election i guess i'll put it
that way
is i think
one of the most prime examples of
what has caused trump people to be trump
people in the first place i mean this
this enormous sect of people in this
country
who just get rolled over they're not
listened to they're not respected nobody
people treat them like they don't exist
and we know that at minimum at minimum
he got 74 million people to come out and
vote for him which is enormous that's
huge
but those 74 million people at minimum
are treated like their concerns don't
matter and i have to say look if it was
literally the other way around
and uh
there were 74 million biden voters who
were outraged and thought the election
was fixed i'd say let's put their mind
at ease let's settle this i don't that's
that's what happened with hillary
clinton because i don't want this to
vote and i just want to mention it's not
just that they're told that their
concerns don't matter they are told that
they have the most abhorrent racist
sexist bigoted concerns you could ever
possibly have they're basically
neo-nazis they're horrible people who
should be excluded from public life if
they ever have the audacity to voice any
of their actual opinions about anything
but i guess my point is that
this was never
this was never worked through this was
never settled at all yeah and in fact
even the people on the left who
who i think in a very sort of elitist
and mocking way address the people who
have concerns on the right you know they
say um
there there's no substantial evidence
that this happened this has all been
discredited this has all been
discredited by who yeah and when no i
mean really
and i don't know people who would never
have wanted it to be true
why would you not want to validate and
verify that you won
that doesn't make any sense to me
rub it in our faces
rub it in our face i mean i just can
assume and it's i assume fear they're
afraid that if they do the right thing
that they'll end up losing and then that
will be the end of the world i don't
know about it that's a drastic firebase
i'm wondering where the arizona audit
stuff went a lot of the stuff that came
out people were like tim why don't you
talk about the arizona stuff i'm like we
did like five times like we had like
multiple guests on who went through the
data we actually sat down with them and
then when the stuff from arizona comes
out it's the same stuff we already
talked about and i was like what am i
supposed to say to this and then they
disappeared
and i'm just like they were checking for
watermarks and stuff and i was like guys
i people want to believe
that the world is something more than it
is i got news for everybody the world is
boring there is no cabal you have people
like bill gates for sure but i've i have
been to uh i've been at davos not for
the actual economic forum but i was in
the peripheral events where people were
setting up
i've i've met with powerful politicians
and ultra-wealthy individuals and
they're clueless at the time they're
just powerful so when they have a whim
they do something crazy
i don't think that there is a you know
beneath the streets of dc hooded figures
our meeting and having these
conversations i know i'm being a little
facetious i don't i don't think that
they secretly meet together i think it's
overt i think you know they're meeting
at bilderberg you know their meeting at
the world economic forum they broadcast
what they're saying from the world
economic forum to the world
that you know when it comes to what
happens with trump they wrote a news
article in time magazine about what they
did
and it was a lot of new voter rules
it was a lot of get out the vote stuff
it was nefarious behind the scenes big
tech billionaires and things like that
and it's it's all out in the open it's
all known what you know how how they how
they did this to trump to fortify the
elections but what's not out in the open
or known is what the dominion servers
tallied it's proprietary and they did it
behind the scenes and then told us what
it said and we just had to take them at
face value if we're going to fortify
this election for real we need some sort
of like third gap where our votes are
put on a blockchain and they can be
observed ian in about dominion
you're right
thank you tim good to see you again
we don't know a proprietary voting
machine we don't know what's on it so i
can certainly see if people are upset
about that my response immediately is
open source publicly available code for
for our voting systems like how could a
private company control that that's
insane to me i'm not i'm not saying
anything nefarious happened i just don't
know because it's private right that's
interesting you guys just brought this
up because i was actually just about to
say it wasn't even for me some of the
more um
i don't know what words to use because i
don't want to offend anybody but like
you know kind of more on the fringe
theories about what went wrong in the
election the watermarks that you know
and and some people
really went pretty far with the dominion
stuff
in my opinion that was never it for me
you know i wasn't really subscribing to
or that to me was not like the key thing
to me it was the stuff like
governors changing voting laws and
manipulating the pandemic which is not
the process you're go you're supposed to
go through to change voting laws it's
supposed to go through the legislatures
and then they had things like well we're
going to extend you know people can mail
them in and we're going to accept the
mail-in until this date well they were
counting ballots that came in three days
or more after the the date and then a
lot of people said they came in they
didn't have signatures that's not okay
the signatures didn't match or weren't
recognized well that's not okay so my
question was only
how many of those ballots did you count
that didn't have signatures or the
signatures didn't match or they came in
after the due date or you know this is
the issue for me too right um we saw a
lot of that i think the universal
mail-in voting stuff gives a massive
advantage to democrats we saw
republicans in georgia and pennsylvania
basically aligned with the democrat
proposals on change to voter rules in in
pennsylvania it was republicans who
actually did a deal with democrats to
create universal mail in voting despite
what the laws actually permitted in the
constitution and so i think the issue is
those are really great points
i think we need to have an investigation
a conversation around that uh
the problem is the media will exploit
the fringe of the conspiracies to
discredit any legitimate questions
around what you know concerns we have in
the election well but you know another
question i have too is
why don't we have a forensic audit of
every election i mean why does it have
to and why why don't we all agree on the
rules ahead of time no matter what
happens and just say after this election
is complete
the this is the way in which it can be
investigated so that both sides feel
satisfied in 2016 they were claiming
that russia and russians hacked voting
machines sheamus brought that up well so
so
i don't know of any specific uh media
conglomerate that said that that was the
case but they were thrilled to be
misunderstood as saying that every time
they said the phrase russian election
interference or russian interference
there are people who genuinely believe
believed that there were there were 50
of democrats believed that russia
literally hacked our voting machines and
they repeatedly said that trump was
illegitimate and all that stuff and that
was all allowed
and they spent tens of millions of
dollars investigating this nonsense then
when trump comes out and says something
like it's a big lie and i'm like dude so
was yours if you want unity in this
country then how about we have the the
the dominion probe like the mueller
probe or whatever but they won't do that
it's a double standard and this is
what's gutting the country and tearing
it apart is that if you have all of
these hillary voters who are freaking
out screaming they got their probe it
jammed up trump for two years then trump
comes out he's angry his supporters are
all angry and they say nah we're not
going to return the favor well that's
how you you shred this country in half
so but so let's move on look i want to
ask you
uh
considering everything you've been
through do you want to give us a
run-through of where you've been like
what's been happening since january 6
to start from the beginning sure
absolutely um
just starting with january 6 forward
well yeah like how did you come to how
did tell us what happened you know yeah
yeah
so um after the election in 2020 um i'd
say somewhere around november
5th or 6th or 7th in those early days
afterwards
um
i was one of the people who decided to
lend my voice there were a number of
conservative
influencers who kind of decided to go to
swing states around the country and
basically throw
rallies and you know first amendment
protected events to kee to encourage
people to basically like keep the energy
up and say hey we want an audit we feel
like something's for everybody i mean
millions of people thought something was
wrong
and uh so i went to the state of
michigan
and i lin i lended my voice to
three rallies when i was there and then
i went to dc for a couple and so i was
very much involved in this what ended up
being called the stop the steel movement
and
uh
on january 6 i got invited to speak in
dc at the capitol um it was
there were graphics that were made for
the speakers i was one of probably a
hundred people or more who had a graphic
that there was supposed to be an event
at the capitol so it was always my
understanding that president trump was
going to speak at the ellipse that there
would be a march from the ellipse to the
capital and that there was going to be a
second event at the capitol uh i was
told it was a permitted event which i
believe it was there was a stage etc
and uh so on that day everything sort of
unfolded for me exactly as i would i was
told that it would president trump said
now we're all going to march peacefully
and patriotically to the capitol and i'm
going to join you there
so i started heading to the capitol on
the dc metro
for my speaking engagement
and um as i was arriving at my stop i
started getting some text messages on my
phone from people who i i'm friends with
or work colleagues of mine who were at
home throughout the country watching on
television saying you know we're hearing
on the news that people are going inside
the building and
i didn't know what that meant because i
have attended dozens and dozens of
right-wing rallies over the years and
that type of thing never happens with
conservative people i mean conservative
people are very very calm peaceful so to
hear that just it sounded strange to me
and honestly the first image that it
brought up in my mind was i thought to
myself when left-wing protesters like
alyssa milano even and amy schumer for a
number of different causes have gone
inside of government buildings have gone
inside the capitol and you know pounded
on
congress people's doors or made noise
gotten dragged out you know usually it
lasts like six seconds and they get
pulled out and the other thing that i
thought was that i was envisioning in my
mind like maybe a dozen people you know
when they're saying people are going
inside i thought like oh you know a few
people went inside to be like we want an
audit and they're going to get pulled
out and whatever
so as i
get to the stop i get off and i'm
heading toward the capitol and i just
decided to start shooting a video and
again i've done enough events to know
that if you're in a large crowd of
people live streaming is just not even a
possibility so i was like you know i'm
just going to record this into my camera
roll on my phone and then if i capture
anything interesting i'll cut it down
and put it out on social media later so
i'm approaching the capital from the
east side this is the east side of the
capital this is the west side of the
capital
this is a very important point to me
that i make every time i do an interview
because the conservative media has done
a terrible job of covering this story so
most people even people who are
supportive of people who got arrested
don't understand this
when you've seen the footage on the news
of
windows being smashed and struggles with
police officers and flashbangs and
things like that as far as i know that
happened exclusively in the crowd on the
west side of the building building
people were breaking windows and going
inside
so i didn't witness any of that
none of that and in my video which
everything i'm about to say
you can watch with your own eye you
don't have to take my word for it just
my video tells the same story i started
shooting my video about three blocks
away from the capitol
and just took one long continuous video
as i'm entering the east side capitol
grounds what you'll see in my video is
that there are zero police officers not
a couple not a zero zero police officers
people are standing all over the grounds
calmly people are walking their dogs
people are
carrying their babies people are
everyone's calm everyone's just
chit-chatting and as i wa there's there
are no barricades uh there's a very very
large sidewalk on the east side i mean
large enough that you could drive cars
on it and it's completely open there's
bike rack over on the left in the lawn
and bike rack over on the right on the
lawn but the sidewalk is open this is
all in my video
i followed the sidewalk up to the
capitol where there were
several thousand people standing around
the steps in my video you see at the top
of the steps a man motioning down to
people below and he's calling out
they've opened the doors they're letting
us in we're going inside we're going
inside
i repeated what he said as i'm filming
and then i went to the top of the stairs
and when i got to the top of the stairs
sure enough both doors were wide open
double doors large metal double doors of
the capital wide open
and there's a crowd of several hundred
people at the top of the stairs
nobody's being violent nobody's hurting
each other anybody
um
it was loud it was a little bit loud but
um
and there were people standing in front
of me you know i was about 35 feet away
from the open doors and a lot of people
taller than me in front of me and people
a lot of people were carrying flags on
poles that were hanging down
so what i did was while my camera was
filming this video i hold my extended my
arms fully above my head and pointed
them down toward the door so that my
camera could capture things that my eyes
could not see and i stood there for
about eight minutes on the east side
steps filming as some people were making
their way into the east side doors open
doors and some people most people were
just standing there either filming or
just kind of watching
and
after about eight minutes a man came
outside of the capitol he got on a bull
horn he shouted into the bullhorn
they've cleared congress everyone's left
the building
clear out clear out
and at that moment i immediately turned
around i told the people behind me
they're saying to clear out go this way
go this way you were you in the building
i never went inside the building i
didn't get within 35 feet of going
inside of the building there were
literally hundreds of people between me
and the doors and the crowd wasn't
really moving it wasn't a quickly it
wasn't a stampede i mean it was
literally just like people kind of
shoulder to shoulder like like going
like this
and um so i left the capitol grounds and
i went back to my hotel room in dc and i
took the video that i just shot and i
uploaded it to twitter
it was um i think about eight and a half
minutes long and i i don't remember what
i said but i think i said something
along the lines of this is what i
witnessed today at the capitol
now at the same time that that was
happening i started to see this energy
changing on twitter where i was starting
to see all these conservative talking
heads expressing like oh my god we're so
ashamed of what happened at the capitol
today we're so embarrassed oh this is
just the worst thing that's ever
happened and i thought that what i had
witnessed with my own eyes and what i
experienced i thought that was it i
thought that was the capital breach and
i'm thinking to myself you know it might
not have been like our finest moment but
i was like you know the doors were open
and people were walking in and you know
i don't know maybe they shouldn't have
gone inside but i'm thinking this is the
most embarrassing thing that people have
ever seen
and so i made a few comments uh you know
saying things like that i was not going
to um uh you know to speak against the
people at the capitol like all the other
conservative talking heads were i said
these are people that are desperate to
be heard nobody's listening to them you
know and
basically the comments that are making
that i was making made it sound like i
was in agreement with whatever had
happened at the capitol
about an hour after i uploaded that
video and had made a couple of comments
i turned on my tv and when i turned on
my tv from my hotel room that's when i
started to see images of people smashing
windows and struggling with police
officers and stuff and i i was really
shocked really really shocked and i was
just like what is this i couldn't even
understand what i was watching footage
of and when they were saying this was
what happened at the capitol i was
thinking
wow okay something went down today that
was very different than what i
experienced
and i instantly knew that people were
going to associate me with that if they
saw my video or they saw my comments and
that no one would be able to distinguish
and understandably no one would be able
to distinguish
i wasn't there i was here that was going
on here i was that you know so i took
the video down i took all my tweets down
for the entire day even the ones i put
on before i went to the capitol i was
just like i don't know what happened i
have no clue what happened at the
capitol and how bad it was so even the
comments that i made you know at eight
in the morning i just don't want and to
be associated with whatever this is in
any way shape or form so i deleted the
video took the tweets down
and honest to god believe that that was
the end of it and flew home the next day
um
and people started asking me right away
was i worried was i concerned because
even though my video had only lived on
twitter for like an hour or two it had
already been copied by numerous twitter
trolls so they were mass
reposting my video and tagging the fbi
and telling the fbi to come and get me
and it was just getting worse and worse
and worse day after day so
uh it wasn't you know going away it was
intensifying and that was making me a
little uncomfortable and at that point i
thought well i'm i'm probably gonna get
visited i i wouldn't be surprised if uh
if they ask me some questions because
this is just getting so and at this
point they were starting to arrest
people and the story was really picking
up and it was picking up but still
people were asking me on a daily basis
are you worried and i was like no i was
like well i didn't do anything i have
nothing to be worried about
and then
uh two and a half weeks later on monday
january 25th
i woke up to a team of fbi agents in
tactical gear raiding my home at dawn uh
they got me out of bed put me in
handcuffs and presented me with a search
warrant uh to take this
a team of agents began taking my
computers my ipad my phones
hard drives thumb drives camera
equipment electronics while
two or three other agents put me in
handcuffs and told me that i was facing
multiple felony charges for what i had
done at the capitol on january 6th and i
remember i said felonies i said i didn't
even commit any crimes and the guy said
oh i saw your video i saw what you did
and i started going what the hell did i
do like i mean i literally like
i just
for a moment i was just like did i like
black out like did i do something like
egregiously violent and i don't remember
it or like what's going on
so they took me to jail
uh they put me in a cell where i sat for
two and a half days
uh before uh in 23 hour day lockdown
before i finally had the opportunity to
see a judge and the judge ordered my
release
when the judge ordered my release the
next morning i was able to speak with an
attorney
and
that's when my attorney who became my
attorney
informed me that i was being charged
with two felonies and a misdemeanor
so the first felony was
knowingly
occupying restricted grounds and this
word is very important to them in all of
these j6 cases knowingly everyone
knowingly was somewhere where they
weren't supposed to be and we chose to
do it anyway and so i guess by standing
on the capitol steps during a protest i
was in a restricted area and i knowingly
was in this restricted area and they
were charging me with a felony for that
and for the record as far as i know
as far as i know i am the only person
who got charged with a felony for being
in the restricted area even people who
went inside the capital were getting
misdemeanors for parading in a
restricted area or occupying a
restricted area but i got a felony for
being on the steps then they charged me
with a misdemeanor of disorderly conduct
with an intent to to disrupt a hearing
before congress
and the other charge was a felony
of impeding an officer in the line of
duty and i said
what is this
and my it was explained to me in your
video that i'm shooting like this of
doors that are 35 feet away from me with
hundreds of people between me and my
camera
there's a moment where one capital
police officer comes to the open doors
the door frame
and when he gets there
the per somebody near him grabs his
plastic shield out of his hand
and when he when that happens a number
of voices it hundreds of people all
around me
a couple of voices in the crowd you hear
one shouting take the shield take the
shield and someone else is shouting take
it take it
well the fbi says you're the person
shouting take the shield take the shield
and you know you're this this influencer
with a lot of uh with a big following
and people listen to you and you have
this influence so by you shouting take
the shield take the shield
this is a you know an egregious act of
encouraging a crowd to impede an officer
and so they charged me with a felony
and um
so that began the process of what was
a year-long nightmare of
trying to find some sort of resolution
in this case what ends up happening with
the charges
long story short after a year
uh i took a plea deal
uh in the plea deal now you have to
understand too that in addition to what
i was already facing
they the doj
repeatedly uh messaged to my attorneys
and to me
that they had not yet
charged me with felony obstruction of
congress and that this was a charge that
carried 20 years they said we could
uh but we haven't we've chosen at this
point not to do that yet
so to me it felt very clear that uh if i
chose not to take the plea deal that
they were offering that i would be
facing the two felonies that they were
already charging me with and that they
were going to add a third felony of
obstruction of congress which carries 20
years
and um when we see the way that these dc
the people who are going to trial when
we see the way that they're going uh you
know people ask me all the time do you
feel like you made the right choice
taking a plea deal and i say well you
have to understand
the the question was never how do i win
and how do i lose it was how do i lose
the least this was an unwinnable
situation so how do i get out of this
and lose the least you know there was
one guy who got acquitted on trespassing
charges that's true he did he took a
bench trial
um the judge himself said that nobody
was trespassing case dismissed right
well i i think
and believe me that sent me into a
depression for a while and questioning
again if i had made the right decision
but the different the key differences in
his case and mine is that if i if if i'm
correct i don't think he was facing any
felonies i think he was facing three or
four misdemeanors and it was a pretty
clear-cut case that he had not committed
any violence vandalism theft or
destruction same with me
but that he was accused of
going inside parading parading in a
restricted area all of these different
things and that he had a video that
showed that there was a police officer
who motioned him in and at that point
the judge was like well this is you
can't charge him with thinking he's in a
restricted area when he has this police
officer motioned him in i'm being
accused of shouting take the shield take
the shield right which i can't disprove
that i didn't simply put the violence in
all of the chaos from that day you
condemn
oh absolutely i always have yeah from
the very beginning so how did it work
out then with the with the plea deal you
took what happened so in the plea deal
they dropped the felony charges against
me they continued forward with the
misdemeanor charge of disorderly conduct
with an intent to disrupt congress
however
as
a piece of my plea deal it included a
document that they call the statement of
offense and in the statement of offense
um i
i it was a condition that i basically
confess to all of the things that they
had originally accused me of so the
statement of offense says
i went onto the grounds knowing that the
grounds were restricted
when i went onto the grounds i saw the
crowd struggling with police officers
and i encouraged the crowd
to struggle with police officers i saw
an officer having a shield ripped away
and i shouted uh take it take it they
changed it uh from take the shield to
take it take it
uh to encourage the crowd to take the
shield and i told my attorney i was like
i cannot sign this i abs i will not sign
this and so my attorney went back to
them and said he
he opposes this
and they said well then he can go to
trial if he has a problem with this this
document so my option was
take the deal as written or go to trial
and i took the deal so either either lie
or face a very serious i'm not saying
that oh okay so uh what how did the
sentencing go what happens next do you
go to the judge so i pled guilty to the
misdemeanor um my sense so they
continued my case five times over the
course of a year which was devastating
and excruciating
um by the time we finally got to
sentencing which was in almost an entire
year i was arrested on january 25th and
i was sentenced on january 24th of the
following year
and um now you have to understand i have
no criminal record
this is uh
a class b misdemeanor charge which my
lawyer said you know this is akin to
playing your music too loud or a class b
misdemeanor yeah and um and the judge
real quick driving on a suspended
license is a class a okay it's like a
it's a harsher offense you get to a year
in jail for that right okay so class b
misdemeanor which the judge herself
referred to as a petty offense i mean
it's classified as a petty offense and i
got sentenced to
three months of house arrest
three years of probation
60 hours of community service the
maximum fine of five thousand dollars i
was ordered to pay 500 restitution to
the capital although it was acknowledged
that i didn't engage in any violence or
vandalism or destruction to the capital
in any way shape or form and uh ordered
to
to engage in court-ordered mental health
services so i had to go to a therapist
court-ordered therapist
and um
and
the government the prosecution actually
asked for during my sentencing the right
to so i'm not so i've already been
sentenced to three years of probation
and the and the prosecution asked for
the right to as a condition of my three
years of probation that they have the
right to surveil my phone my computer my
email account my bank accounts and my
social media accounts for the three
years that i was on probation but the
judge did not grant them that but they
wanted it they wanted it
already doing that what right right
right just like you don't need it uh
what is probation what does that look
like what does that mean well you know
at this point i'll say that i'm
fortunate because i have a
a good probation officer and i think i i
don't want she's never said anything to
me to indicate how she feels about my
case but based off of the way she
interacts with me
um i get the indication that she sees
the case for what it is and feels like
she has better things to do with her
time than be managing me on a constant
basis but what does that what does it
mean for you like when you wake up you
got to call them or
how strict is it you want to go buy
groceries they're like you can't have
milk you're gaining weight or something
like that
no i mean by the way house of thank you
thank you house arrest was like that um
i was quite literally not allowed to
leave my house for three months unless i
was doing community service which was
restricted i mean it's 60 hours so i had
the option to leave my house for 60
hours to do community service they gave
you an ankle monitor i was i had an
ankle monitor
during that three months and um she
would make routine visits to my house
and i did occasionally have to leave and
do uh your analysis and things like that
um
uh probation now that i'm off house
arrest probation is has not so far been
particularly strict
she's gone above and beyond to make sure
that i have the right and ability to
travel as needed she's not trying to
restrict restrict me from being able to
move around and do the work that i need
to do
in fact the only real inhibitions that i
might ever face is so uh coming here to
do this show or anywhere else i might
need to go
uh let's just use as an example the
state of california if i need to travel
to the state of california for any
business or
okay
how about texas
all right if i need to travel to the
state of texas for any reason she has to
um contact the district in texas that
i'm traveling to their probation office
and then they have to what's the purpose
of his travel what's he doing where is
he staying what's his flight number is
he renting a car what's the rental car
information so they have to gather all
this information and then they make a
determination about if they have any
issue with me traveling there or not so
it could technically happen but so far
has not happened yet and i've traveled
to
a number of blue districts where so far
no one has caused an issue and in fact
i'll be going to washington dc how do
you feel about the uh the response from
independent conservative media
starting with everything that happened
do you feel that your story was
accurately represented that would imply
that there was any so
um no it's been terrible i mean it's
been terrible i've pushed really really
really hard to get my story out and i've
gotten to the point where
i've been successful and you know i was
interviewed by mark levin on levin tv i
just sat down with tucker carlson two
weeks ago on fox nation so we sat down
for an hour uh and that's on fox nation
uh but these have all been the result of
me pushing really hard for them to tell
my story
very few people have come to me and been
like this story needs to get out the
people need to know what happened i
think it's more of like a snowball
rolling down a hill you know i i i
hadn't heard much about the story at all
yeah and then uh we we're hearing it now
i'm sure a lot of people are going to
hear it a lot of people are going to
want to know more and there's probably a
bunch of questions we'll have i think i
think more conversations will happen
well i'm incredibly grateful to you and
thank you for having me on no because
honestly
as far as the internet goes this is
certainly the biggest exposure that i've
had
in terms of the podcast no i mean that
and and i i mean honestly if there are
people i mean look if you if you started
a podcast yesterday and you have 13
don't reach out to me
like don't but i mean for anybody out
there who is a podcaster with a
significant audience i'm happy to come
on and talk we we booked you the same as
we would we booked anybody else like
normal you know what i mean it wasn't
there was no
politics no debate yeah i was just like
hey brandon once i was like oh cool what
um what would you do different if there
was like another or what advice would
you give if people wanted to protest
legally at the capitol and there was
something akin to what happened how
would you have done it how would you do
it differently and how would you advise
people to go about that situation and
not get into trouble but still get the
point across such a great question so
i think probably the biggest lesson i
learned from this was two things number
one we do absolutely exist in a
two-tiered system of justice so if you
are a conservative you're under much
more scrutiny than perhaps if you
support the black lives matter movement
or if you're a member of antifa or a
number of left-wing protesters who do
this kind of thing all the time like
jane fonda who stood exactly where i
stood five fridays in a row uh uh
protesting climate change and was
arrested five fridays in a row and had
her charges dropped for all five times
that she was arrested so there is a
two-tiered system of justice so you need
to be aware that if trouble breaks out
get the hell out of there as fast as you
can because you can find yourself
ensnared in something unwittingly uh and
you they're not going to let you off
i mean their favorite thing in the world
is to put out a a headline that says you
know trump writer
dot dot dot you could be a 67 year old
woman with no criminal record you could
be 73 years old they don't care it's as
long as they get the trump right or
headline that's all that's important the
second thing i would say is
be really really aware
that
there could be a lot more going on than
what you're witnessing with your own
eyes i mean that to me personally is
probably the biggest lesson i didn't
stop to consider that this is a
four-sided building with people on all
four sides and that there could be
something much larger going on on any of
these sides than what i was witnessing
with my own eyes it's almost like the
jurisdiction's so big it should be
quadranted off so that you would only
charge people in certain quadrants with
activity within that quad that would be
fair like that's like a city block you
don't arrest a guy on the left side of
this in the west side of city block is
what somebody on the east side did that
would be fair uh and
and that's again to me one of the
biggest fail failures from the
conservative media of not even me like i
have made that point to people like
tucker cross i'm brilliant people mark
levine tucker carlson almost everyone i
talk to says wow i didn't even think of
that and i'm like yeah i mean there were
any
you could be arrested on january 6th for
being on capitol grounds and throwing a
gum wrapper on the ground and you know
get a littering charge but you're still
going to be listed mega rioter arrested
on january 6th because you happen to be
anywhere in the vicinity of that
building and got arrested i mean
i honestly do believe that what happened
to me is absurd
but
if
you know if they had come to me and said
look you're a big influencer you've got
a large audience we're charging you with
a misdemeanor of disorderly conduct i
would have been like
okay i mean if you really feel like you
need to do this fine but the idea that i
was at one point possibly facing three
felony charges for eight minutes that i
stood outside of the capitol holding a
camera in my hands they acknowledged
there was never one moment where anyone
said we think you might have been
violent we think you might have been uh
van
vandalizing we think you might have been
destroying property they said from the
beginning we know you didn't do any of
those things but we do think that uh
they they said that they thought that
that was my voice i i don't believe that
they thought that but they said that
they thought that that was my voice and
um
that was the harshest thing i mean that
was the biggest thing that i was accused
of was saying the words take it take it
and um
i ended up at one point almost facing
three felony charges of that because on
the other side of the building
crazy things were happening
they want to make an example i suppose
well they weren't even that wasn't even
a secret in the 30-page sentencing
recommendation that they wrote on my
misdemeanor charge
they said numerous times you should read
it oh man uh did i do something funny
what i got charged with i brought the
suspended license thing because i've
been charged with a class a misdemeanor
once you know my penalty was what it was
i think 150 fun
that's it well good for you and they
said and they said my mind's bigger than
your [ __ ] well no no my point is the
absurdity of what you went through on a
class b disorderly conduct yeah so uh
when i was i think i told the story
before i was i think i was 19 or 20.
i didn't know that if you got two
speeding tickets they suspended your
license
and i didn't what i was going to fight
one of them because it was bunk it was a
bad ticket but i was like it's easier
just to pay it and i asked a family
member just to cover it for me instead
of having to deal with going to court i
didn't realize that was in a mission of
guilt i was like 19 and so then i'm
driving back from colorado i get pulled
over the cop says you're under arrest
suspended license i was like what i was
like i was in colorado i just got back i
had no idea and they're like tell it to
a judge
so i got eye bonded they even arrest me
they take me out of the car they say
you've been formally arrested here's
your ticket here's your court date
that's it i went to court
prosecutors had class a misdemeanor one
year in jail 2500 fined maximum penalty
if you plead guilty 150 bucks and i was
like okay
so that's it and it's a longer
the longer story is like i told the
judge i was being coerced because they
were threatening me with a year in jail
and he told me to get a lawyer talked to
a lawyer ultimately i said i guess i'll
plead guilty and they said 150 bucks you
can pay it right now and you're done and
this is off your record and i was like
wow for a class a misdemeanor tim's like
i could make way more than that in the
year that i would be in prison right but
the opportunity the reality was
a year in jail was never on the table no
judge or jury would sentence someone to
that right they always try to scare you
with the maximum but a 30-page
sentencing recommendation on a class b
misdemeanor oh yeah something doesn't
add up no no no and you know they went
through my social media
i was actually going to bring this up
earlier when you were talking about
people uh taking your your video clip
out of context where you were talking
about the the weapons and stuff nukes
i mean imagine if it wasn't left-wing
trolls but the department of justice
that's doing that to you because that's
literally
in my 30-page sentencing recommendation
and again people can look this up for
themselves it's all over online
they a number of times they went through
my tweets and things like that and they
would take
words out of different tweets and string
a sentence together like i'm not making
this up it's in there like one of the
sentences in my sentencing
recommendation
because they wanted me in prison by the
way they wanted prison time for my eight
minutes outside of the capitol holding a
camera and
one of the things that they said was you
know if you look at mr strzok's twitter
he tells the patriots that we are in a
civil war and that we've got to fight
back if we don't want to i mean
literally these are all from different
tweets and they strung together a
sentence the washington post look it up
the washington post did a story saying
mega influencer was calling for a civil
war about me it's a story about me
calling for a civil war i'm like i was
on the steps with my camera
you know but that's what that's what
this is trump these are press releases
you see what they did with trump he
re-truth someone who said civil war and
they were like trump calls for a civil
war that's right it was probably me
washington post it says january 6th in
florida oh they changed the sub the
title first originally said brandon
strzok stewart rhodes both call for
civil war quote and then they would go
to the website if they change it jan six
influencers call for civil well that's
better yeah yeah okay realize there's no
defamation now here's the new story
donald trump retrieved someone who said
the word civil war that's the story if
you didn't say so what you can infer
from that is if you didn't call for
civil wars there's a defamation case the
washington post claims you did the tweet
that i put out that they got that from
was me saying
make your peace right now with the fact
that we're in a civil war i said we
didn't want it and we didn't call for it
but they've started it something now i
want to even clarify that statement
when we talk about a modern civil war
we're not talking about people grabbing
their muskets and going out and like you
know going to the battlefield or
something i'm talking about being uh
banned from like i have been banned from
using paypal venmo stripe i'm not
allowed to send funds back and forth
people are literally having their bank
accounts shut down that's what a modern
civil war looks like it looks like when
people have a political ideology and
they control all the technology and
they're preventing people from being
able to exist in the digital space
that to me is what a modern civil war
looks like let's go to one more time
well it's i kind of wanted to ask you
something oh yeah is that okay
so
when i got out of jail um
i was having a really hard time you know
and everyone was advising me don't
don't open the news
don't google yourself and don't open
your social media which i
held out for about two weeks um before
it was just like nagging at me and i was
like what are they saying what are they
saying
so one of the first things that i saw
was a piece you did while i was still in
jail
and basically in that you were reading
through the story of my arrest document
and what i was being accused of and
things like that and if i recall
correctly and i think i do
you were basically being objective and
kind of neutral and saying like well wow
if he did this then you know and i think
you were feeling a certain kind of way
about it
do you feel in retrospect
like
you didn't understand what they were
doing with january like
did you think it was possible that i
would like go to the capitol and try to
be like let's f up some police officers
today and let's but yeah i mean it's
like what you said when you've got uh
video showing people doing these things
and then there was a video that you were
posting showing on the capitol grounds
right we i'm not i'm not ignition i know
i just i just i'm not mad at you right i
assume like you're up there with
everybody yelling these things or
whatever you know what i mean
that's why i got carried away or that
yeah i mean i thought a lot of it was
i've long maintained like they opened
the door for doors for people they fan
people in they were the cops were taking
selfies with people and some people were
fighting and we saw you know everything
like richie mcginnis captured so i
certainly didn't think you like ripped
your shirt off and were swinging or
anything like that
but the idea that you could have been
with a crowd of people and you were
filming and or yelling something i was
like i mean it's plausible sure and i
guess to that point too this is uh the
reason why i brought this up earlier and
i didn't really clarify this when i made
the comment about not being able to live
stream and therefore recording a video
to my camera roll
the reason why in my opinion that's
relevant is
i made a conscious decision to go back
to my hotel and upload my video to
twitter i wasn't streaming live and
something broke out and i got caught up
in the moment and then i was like oh god
i just did that on camera in front of my
followers and it like
i made a decision later to upload my
video to twitter to my conservative law
and order pro police base on twitter who
would
hate
seeing me encouraging an attack on a
police officer now to be clear i've
already pled guilty to this misdemeanor
and i've already confessed to the
accusation against me i'm just saying i
think a reasonable reasonable person
should ask themselves why would i do
that
why would i even if i got carried away
in the moment and decided to jump in
with what the audience was doing
make a decision later to show my
audience that
who would hate it
we gotta go to super chats
we gotta go we're talking about yeah
yeah
uh
you know we often point out the media
lies but i also often point out that we
do our we still use a lot of these same
sources and we we do our best to try and
verify a lot of it
if what i was reading was was untrue and
it appears that it was i am sincerely
sorry if i presented any false narrative
about what actually happened with you
based on um my my inaccurate assessments
well i do not accept your apology
well that's okay so all right time to
rip the shirts off and i'm done with you
yeah right right uh it's it's a
challenge it is it's uh
you know like i said i'm like reading
court documents and i'm like wow you
know like if that's if that's true i try
to be skeptical a lot of things but to
be clear i was never upset with you
about it and i i really did feel like
you were doing your job i uh it the only
part that sucked was being i mean
immediately you have to i got out of
jail and the very next morning i saw my
attorney and my attorney said do not go
don't don't post don't make a statement
don't say and he said i don't and that
was part of the reason why they said
don't read the news and don't open your
social media because he knew i would be
reactionary and he was like just avoid
it because you cannot respond so when
i'm seeing like people like you you know
who are just kind of like wow i you know
if he if he did this and i'm going but i
didn't but i didn't you know and yeah
let's uh let's go to super chats because
we're a little behind we gotta we gotta
see a lot of people have questions if
you haven't already uh please smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show if you're a big fan uh
head over to timcast.com we have a
members only show coming up at about 11
p.m
let's read some more we got here
the one free man says
if they were trying to avoid a civil war
conflict someone would be thrown under
the bus for this at this point they're
flaunting they cannot be touched they
know the people are getting pushed to
the breaking point and that's reference
to sussman i believe
so these are the super chats from
earlier
so yeah
reggie 1971 says a russia russia gate
reporter winning a pulitzer was like
millie vanilli winning a grammy
beautiful
tom bemore says brandon pleading was a
mistake people who take it the easy way
out are the exact reason why the
government thinks that they can get away
with behavior like they displayed at
ruby ridge
well tom maybe the fbi will come to your
house at some point and you'll find
yourselves in the position yourself in
the position i was in and you can show
us how it's done this is uh it's tough
man
uh i don't know how i would respond in a
situation like you're in you know uh i
was there's a story i've told about when
i was facing like a disorderly conduct
charge
like they told me it was 20 hours
community service at my own discretion
and i demanded a jury trial and they
ultimately dismissed the charge because
of it very different from the fbi
january 6th right coming january 6. i
would 100 be found guilty
100
feds have like what is like a 99
conviction rate wow yeah not like state
level stuff right so it's it's my point
ultimately is like it's easy to for a
lot of people to say you know i would go
for it
i typically say stuff like this but i
wouldn't i wouldn't even
i wouldn't know where to begin something
like this when you've got the weight of
the federal government yes and you see
what's going on around this you see like
look what's going on with sussman and
all this stuff
yeah and they're telling people they're
going to add additional charges they're
going to add terrorism enhancements and
you've got polls coming out saying that
67
of potential jurors believe that every
january 6 person is guilty like
they won't release jurisdiction there no
these all these trials have to happen in
dc with a dc judge and a dc jury
no i will say though
um knowing the bias you see what
happened with the january 20th antifa
j17 i'm sorry jay 20th the 2017 rioters
the city of dc actually paid them
why
they the police because they were all
wearing black block couldn't figure out
who did what so they charged them with
conspiracy lost and then the lawsuit was
filed and the city was forced to pay out
millions of dollars
and they went around smashing windows
starting fires burned they torched a
limousine it was it was nuts i was there
when they were the police were fighting
their flash bangs all over the place i'm
pretty sure luke was there as well but
it was mostly peaceful fires mostly yeah
absolutely i actually got arrested that
day
um but i was not processed that was cut
loose when i you know i waved over to it
when kyle's just bragging at this point
about all the times he's gotten
congratulations nothing ever sticks to
me yeah
you know i made a call to bill i was
like billy what's up mr gates uh yeah
i'm i'm being arrested you call him
awesome and then epstein was there and
they were like you're part of the santa
clause and santa claus clearly hillary
clinton gave me a hug and she's like i'm
so sorry that happened to you
no this was um i stood next to some
journalists and kept my mouth shut
and then when the when the news
organization called it in i waved to the
cop and he's like where's your press
pass and i showed him as i get out of
here so i was in that group of of the
people who got uh uh arrested and i'd
like to say thank you to these auntie
for people because i was pepper sprayed
and they gave me the uh milk of magnesia
or whatever stuff maylox
so like my neck was sprayed directly and
it was burning
and they have malox what is that stuff
that's for heartburn oh okay yeah i
don't think that's it yeah like no
that's what they spray pepper spray oh
it's just not milk or magnesia yeah and
so they they were like i was like dude
it when you get a direct pepper spray
right on your neck and i'm just like i
can't get it off and so they sprayed it
oh man that's like capsaicin shut up
yeah yeah yeah
all right
i
kefka says sheamus says he will love you
forever who is you it's a good question
so if you go over to freedomtunes.com to
the members section you get five dollars
a month it says it says is one of the
tears i will you know i will love you
forever if you give follow us
and i follow through i will love you
he's the real deal that's right thank
you ian
that's that but that is actually what
they're referencing that was that was
not just a
you know in my usual style of shameless
plug that is what it says in the five
dollar a month subscription joseph
garcia says trump lost because tim voted
for him oh what does that mean i don't
know you jinxed it yeah
do you think that's real jinxing
no one i've ever voted for has ever won
so yes
phillip reed says hey tim i used to have
some hope that police were good until i
saw the body cam footage from the george
floyd riots where the police went around
in unmarked vans shooting at people with
40 millimeter rubber bullets and
laughing while making jokes
wow i don't remember that one do you
guys remember that negative oh that's
crazy sound is that real don't know
what it what is this
oh of course you don't got to ask well
brandon's like can i can i promote stuff
i'm like yeah oh of course yeah he's
being faithful
we'll read super chats and then before
we wrap we'll do uh yeah perfect here's
me shamelessly plugging my website
jason lindholm says gas price in far
west burbs aurora illinois and west is
5.55 yeah i just paid 550 today on the
way back from ohio it was crazy time
crazy did it feel like joe biden was
sucking my soul
out of my body while you're here i'm
going to put this in the minds of
everybody so you can never escape i'm
taking my headphones off from the world
you're pumping gas every time
that's gross and while you're popping
you're like
let me let go i love that all the gas
remember the car rent house meme where
he's holding the gas pump and crying and
then the gas started dripping down the
sidewalk towards my foot and i was like
oh no no no it's gross if you've ever
seen like a bartender pour like an
expensive shot they have like an eye
dropper and they're like very careful
they'll make sure the drips go back in
because it's expensive that's what's
like with gas now yeah it's like a drop
hits the ground and you're like
i'm always trying to catch it when you
pull it out you try to swirl it around
so it doesn't drip on the ground
it's not good
michael mccord says couple tim's
sarcastic gas price rant with ian's stop
light tesla convo idea make the grey
poupon commercial
what
stop light tesla i got that part what
was the first one that you want to mix
together my my fake rant about gas
prices that's great dude satanic muffin
says bring on malice or expose my
phallus uh michael malus has an open
invitation come on the show whenever he
wants but he's got his own show and so
you know just yell at him until he comes
on the show yes we'll be back
he will return in the sequel the great
malicious return waffle sensei says i
voted for abide in the democratic
primaries because i thought biden was
the weakest of all the candidates and
easiest for trump to beat obviously the
joke is on me now but the parties do
vote in each other's primaries fair
point fair point
glenn wellen says great show tim my
guess is the democrats flipping just to
sabotage it's actually just them trying
to justify the clear republican
advantage in the votes
right that's what i was thinking maybe i
also wonder if people are like i'm i'm
voting republican because i met at trump
that explains it and they're secretly
like i hope trump wins you know oh the
republicans take this one
melissa wood says ga voter here i have
never voted in the primary until may
24th for kemp it's a far more complex
issue than trump we've had experience
with kemp and purdue trump has more poll
with unknown candidates i.e j.d vance
interesting
bi says tim i love the american flag
behind the irish guy do you have a merch
store i'd buy it the flag is the flag
not the irish guy
no you're not supposed to buy it
unbelievable
i'm also an irish guy oh no
we're talking about doing yeah we're
talking about doing woke commercials for
tim cast irl and like when we mentioned
our diversity we point to sheamus as our
minority
thank you for growing the beard look i'm
a woman actually
[Laughter]
neil williams says i only became more
conservative because of covid i don't
like the i don't like fear being the
reason for losing our rights remember
911 because of fear we got the patriot
act keep calm and carry on in my opinion
remember every day thank you yeah man
that patriot act that 911 the response
to 911 was like so extreme
oh just to live through that man wow i
never want to live through something
like that again and i was so stupid i
was one of those stupid liberals back
then i was like well if you're not doing
anything wrong why do you care if the
government's watching you like how did
that break yeah yeah yeah um moxie
marlin spike i don't know if you guys
have ever heard of him he made a really
great point i interviewed him once he i
think he created signal was it signal oh
yeah i think so i love that uh and
everybody was a signal so this is the
guy who made it he he said the easiest
the simple thing
if
why the government shouldn't spy on you
he says we are seeing marijuana
legalization across this country
but it was illegal across this country
how did people know they wanted it to be
legal
they were doing it if the government can
spy on everything you do there's never
an opportunity for society to reflect
and change its mind because no one can
engage with things that are illegal
unless you go to jail that's an
interesting point yeah it is yeah it is
all right mo ma says dr carolyn
carlin stood up for you that whole time
yeah
all right nice work jeremy uh abramson
says hey brandon from a member of the
fundamentalist religious right you have
fantastic eyebrows oh well thank you
there's actually a twitter account
dedicated to my app
what's the name of that account it's
brandon strzok's eyebrows that's great
a real twitter account pamela white says
jan 6 congressional hearings will be the
tipping point for midwest americans
truth be told
you know
that's a great point too this is a good
one tom peeny says brandon's story
reminds me of the stories in the gulag
archipelago archipelago they would make
people sign ridiculous documents for
crimes they didn't even commit and still
torture them and send them to the gulag
scary
got viva fry in the chat is it fry or is
it frey hello fried freddy freight fry
thank you spray freight
fright
viva says it's not just the excessive
sentence and fines imagine the excessive
costs of enforcing these idiotic
sanctions the parole officer the court
costs state-funded persecution
yeah and time time is valuable
yeah that's right
australians versus the agendas i got
thrown in jail for three months in
australia five months parole for
organizing a protest taken to a super
max jail given six charges nobody got
sanctioned worse
google anthony kaloof
interesting
all right
soleil cucumber lime says democrat
orthodoxy is based on humiliation it's a
communist propaganda technique i'm a
registered d will never vote for these
people ever again yes
yeah i won't i won't
there's nothing they could do and
they're like we need a moderate you know
democrat and they talk about beto and
i'm like get out of here with these
authoritarian crackpots beto o'rourke
was like heck yeah we're taking your
guns or you're taking your air 15. now
he's like i don't want to take anything
from anybody shut up
duplicitous bunch of kids died he saw it
as an opportunity to grandstand yeah
good for him
touchy's subject says tim is right there
is no pedo cabal and we will uh hillary
clinton anybody who says otherwise just
ask epstein and gillane maxwell and
jimmy seville so let me let me uh
clarify
uh yeah epstein was real everybody we
know that elaine maxwell was convicted
but uh her customers where are they no
crime and uh my point was more
specifically about the actual political
class i don't know the extent to which
epstein you know reached we know about
the plane we know about the little black
book we know about the people are going
to that island
a lot of questions that need to be
answered joe biden literally sniffs kids
okay yeah weird i i i my point is guys
we know the epstein stuff is legit
but as bad as it is it was literally
powerful elites getting on a plane and
flying to an island right
creepy stuff also the fbi swarmed the
island and uh
ostensibly there was some evidence there
of some people's wrongdoing and yet no
one was uh charged
yeah interesting
i always make a joke about luca going to
the island yeah but luke's not here so i
was like i can't really make that joke
yeah so
luke witkowski after the raid he went he
filmed and documented parts of the
island so i always tell people like
luke's been abstinent and they go whoa
whoa he's like whoa whoa not like that
not like that not like that
a murray says
tim armalite needs a rebranding also
considering the fed is likely listening
because of brandon dangerous criminal
abolish the government black flag
i love how like when you see a black
flag on twitter you don't know if it's a
good black flag or a bad black flag
because the woke authoritarians use a
black flag too because they don't know
what anarchy means i guess yeah i guess
not and they just like
but then you'll like i'll i periodically
see people with black flags and like
we're in total agreement and i'm like
okay it's one of the good anarchists
it's kind of like the lgbt flag too
quite honestly when i see it i just
automatically assume it's like a lunatic
and then every once while they're like
no i'm a gay trump supporter too and i'm
like oh yeah
take the stupid rainbow down
misleading
i think i think christians need to bring
the rainbow back um
you know i think it might send a
different message than i would be
intending to send with it if it was like
an actual full-fledged rainbow maybe we
do got to take it back is that a
christian
yeah
and also a jewish thing right the flood
god sent a rainbow to promise you
wouldn't flood the world again really
yeah
take it back i saw this rainbow when i
was driving across the country and then
all of a sudden it appeared into a huge
rainbow i saw like a bit of it i thought
it was the whole rainbow and then all of
a sudden i could see the whole rainbow
yeah i can see full circle rainbows
sometimes all right let's read some more
the last says strzok did the right thing
dc juries or judges could have given him
20 years for doing nothing but
supporting trump i will thank you i will
say too as well considering what we're
seeing with the the the clinton
russiagate stuff and how these people
walk these are dc jurors oh it's all
swamp it's all swamp don't you also have
to hire a dc lawyer nick cersei was
talking about that when he was here no
my lawyer was not attacking her okay
but i will tell you thank you for
correcting that then yeah no worries but
i will tell you that although it's
possible that nick cersei did not say
that i don't want to put that on him
either i could have misremembered there
is some sort of certification that you
have to have to be able to practice like
in that jurisdiction and my lawyer who
was a nebraska lawyer was certified to
do that the one thing i was going to say
really quickly is that almost every
lawyer who's making their way through
these cases
including mine who had decades of
federal trial experience
they've never seen anything like this i
mean all of them are coming out of this
and being like what just happened
because they've never seen a doj so
weaponized before we are we are in a
political civil war oh well you said it
not me oh yeah you know of course i mean
i say civil war all the time but
what i'm saying is
right now we talk about civil war when i
do at least i won't speak for anybody
else i mean like a broad big picture of
an era of conflict which will culminate
in some kind of dramatic moment i don't
know exactly what will happen
uh we can we can take we had stephen
marshall the show who wrote the book the
next civil war and he said civil strife
which is the precursor to civil war when
you have i think what do you say 70
people per year dying for political
reasons
when i say political civil war
donald trump hillary clinton democrats
impeachment all that stuff they're using
the weight of the legal system
law fair and law enforcement to go after
their opponents it's kind of like
they've always been doing it but there
was a curtain up and now we pulled the
curtain back and we're getting the
residual like
blast effect of it no no bro bro
i disagree man i mean there was dirty
politics for sure and they probably went
to lesser known candidates who had a
chance of winning like bernie and been
like don't play with us where the
establishment this is different
if donald trump wins in 2024
i really think he's gonna it's gonna be
like super saiyan 3 goku that the wavy
hair is going to extend really long he's
going to rip his shirt off and be super
ripped and floating with energy
protruding from he's going to
yeah he's going to fire everybody he's
going to he's going to send the doj at
tons of people
i think
i hope so but imagine what they're going
to do in response to that they know
that if donald trump wins again
that it is lights out it is the the the
system will will will be stripped of its
power the establishment will be gutted
god that sounds great that's why i'm
like look i was saying i was in the
daily wire last month and i was like i
think desantis would be better at this
point than trump but i'm also wondering
if desantis is going to try and play
nice if he's going to be like i'm going
to do what the people want but i'm not
going to do that trump's going to be
like i am going to politically
strip this system
yeah no i i just like to shameless i'm
waiting for him
quite frankly
i thought about it i went in there i
said you're fired okay that's it you got
no no severance package you're just gone
yeah
yeah i wonder i i do wonder what happens
if he does get back into office i really
i would like to help provide some
resistance for him to knock his head
against metaphorically to learn but like
just think outside the is if it's
political in-fighting we're done man
maybe not done but it's going to be a
lot of conflict if we go at each other
politically but if we create cool
technologies and we focus people's
energy on it right i think we'll be okay
i wish it was easy
i wish we could say that if we all just
chilled out and worked with each other
it'd all be over but i think the reality
is that if we don't go after the swamp
and take out the corruption then the
corruption will reign supreme it's weird
because it's like the corruptions in my
head and i don't want to smash my head
there's a better way it's like a detox
we need to detect it's not
look we're talking about the legacy of
revolving door politics someone who runs
a big company gets a kickback you know
they they retire and then get a job in
government someone who works at a major
pharmaceutical will get a job at the fda
or whatever someone in a major
agricultural company will get a job at
the usda and just one big circle
halliburton cheney becomes vice
president then we get new wars
if the swamp isn't drained and trump did
not drain it then the corruption reigns
supreme i have i have a feeling trump
is he's like
i'm just imagining him sitting in a dark
room like rocking back and forth like
the time will come
i actually just visited a drain swamp
when i was back in my hometown there
used to be a a swamp and it would flood
the neighboring houses they ended up
planting a bunch of plants that absorbed
the water and helped it now fall down
into the earth through this
otherwise would have been a swamp
let's read a couple more here's a story
ian yeah let's go with politics
megan cox says brandon i am sorry that
many on the right abandoned you i didn't
thank you megan dude what could we have
done not maybe i'll ask about this later
let's do some more super chats i'll ask
you maybe on the after show we talk
about this spiro fluoropolis
according to sources say dot online
nancy pelosi wants to impeach trump
because he farted into a telephone that
sounds right and then he said you did it
you did it i gotta check back to the
beginning of the episode
so we had this idea
wikipedia basically can't be sued
because uh section 230
but the the issue is that if someone
writes a a sentence like you know
sheamus does a backflip
that's and it's true it's fine but if
someone then changes backflip to you
know punched a dog and sheamus punched a
dog they didn't actually say he did they
only changed a single word interesting
so my idea was a website where everyone
gets to queue up for one word to add to
the story
so you open it and it'll say nancy
pelosi
you know wanted to impeach wants to
impeach trump because he blank and it's
your turn to write a word and you put
farted
then someone else gets to write the next
word and puts into and then someone puts
the telephone or whatever so this guy
spiro made the thing so anyway my
friends if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show head over to
timcast.com we have a members only show
coming up at 11 p.m
and uh this one's interesting i wonder
how many feds are gonna have to buy a
membership to watch
all
uh you can follow the show at tim cast
irl follow us on instagram we post clips
from the show every day you can follow
me at timcast on twitter and instagram
branded you want to shout anything out i
really do actually so my organization is
right now coming back uh we got stripped
pretty hard this uh past year but uh one
of the first live events that we're
doing is going to be saturday june 11th
in scottsdale arizona we're doing an
event with a gubernatorial candidate
carrie lake who i think is an amazing
america first tough as nails hard on the
media
hard on crime hard on immigration she's
amazing
and uh so we're doing an event in
scottsdale arizona june 11th saturday
and for anybody who's in the arizona
area they can get tickets by going to
walkawaycampaign.com and you should be
able to link right there on the home
page and really really really make the
effort you guys because this isn't just
about like having a fun night coming out
and hearing people speak and stuff it's
really about helping support my
organization make its comeback because
we got leveled pretty hard and so if you
uh if you believe in a movement of
people walking away from the democratic
party if you want to see this movement
come back in full swing come out and
help support us go to
walkawaycampaign.com it's gonna be great
and also i would also love it if people
would follow me on twitter
on facebook um somehow i still have my
accounts those didn't get taken away but
i'm being throttled really really hard i
used to have amazing engagement on
twitter and i'm having a rough time so
go to uh brandon strzok i have a search
ban so you have to type the whole thing
brandon s-t-r-a-k-a
uh that's facebook twitter i'm on truth
i'm on getter i'm on youtube please
follow me on everything and retweet
retweet retweet and share
and tell your friends
should i keep going tell your friends we
have another hour what else you got
let's skip sheamus and go right to ian i
don't
know
i want to shout out
you can sign up for sheamus uh i got so
excited i broke my chain she really did
you earned it baby thank you i
appreciate it
is there you want to get cute on camera
for a second or anything you got going
on yeah i just wanna i just wanna plug
this first look i'm always cute on
camera
no but i so yeah freedom tunes if you
guys want to go over there check out the
cartoons we just released something
today we re-edited an old video that
happened to work very well with justin
trudeau i recommend you guys check that
out it's a funny one we're going to be
releasing one on thursday and also we
just launched our website and on this
website you can get access to one
cartoon per week that the public does
not get so that then you're getting like
10 freedom tunes a month as opposed to
the usual six and we're also uploading a
good amount of behind-the-scenes stuff
there so freedomtunes.com become a
member support the show help us get an
independent from big tech uh and thank
you so much you can get through uh get
through to me through ian crossland.net
if you want to get in touch with any of
my socials also i got a book that i i
wrote about i don't know 10 years ago or
so now when we were starting minds uh i
was one of the co-founders and i used to
live i was living on the street for a
while and i documented it and man it is
a wild ride through my mind so you can
check that it's called writing in the
dark
it's uh it's pretty interesting more of
a manuscript or a diary or something but
it's on amazon you can get it there and
i'll catch you later very cool check out
ian's manifesto if you're so inclined
you guys may follow me on twitter
mines.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlist.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you